Thank you.
All right, it is 4 o'clock.
As soon as I get everybody's attention.
I should.
You guys ready?
Ready as you are.
All right.
Do you need a baton, do you?
I've got a next one.
Yeah, I need more than that.
I got one.
We're rolling.
All right.
It's 4 o'clock, according to this clock.
And we'll go ahead and call this work session to order and get started.
And the first thing on our agenda is a discussion.
I propose an update to the annexation policy, Area 7, and Mr. Brandon.
It seems like we were just here discussing this, because we were.
So we've had a few things develop in the sense that time.
So if you'll remember, at the end of February, or excuse me, the end of the year, 1st of December-ish,
end of November, we approved a new annexation plan.
And since that time, a few things have developed.
I'll remind you of this.
As soon as I can get my screen up, I'll show you the.
There we go.
I think it's coming.
All right.
So this is what we got approved.
And this was six areas.
Since that time, we have had, there's resources that we've become aware of, obviously.
There's some potential strategic resources that may be of value to the area, to the region,
really, to the country.
And so what this proposal is, is to add an Area 7.
That area, and I'm going to take you down here, and I'll back up here in a second,
but just to give you a little context.
So on the, let me pop this up here.
So old map, without Area 7, proposed Area 7 right there on the right-hand side.
That's really all this is about, is adding Area 7.
That's land that's owned by the state of Utah.
There's some federal lands in there, and a handful of other landowners.
And so this process, we're going through a process with, in taking this back through.
There's no way to, like, amend an annexation plan.
There's not an amended process to amend your annexation plan.
So we're just taking it back through, which means we have to take it to affected entities.
We have to have two planning commission meetings, and then a council meeting.
And so we've had our affected entity meeting.
Didn't hear back from anybody yet.
We're currently in a 10-day period where we can continue to receive feedback from affected entities.
Haven't seen, haven't heard anything, but we're still in that window.
So, again, annexation plans are just our signal of saying, hey, this land is land that we're willing to consider annexation proposals for.
So we're not saying this, all these orange areas are necessarily coming to the city.
We're just saying, hey, we'd consider proposals.
And then you'll remember, may remember, it's not just a map.
An annexation policy plan is a decision-making guide.
Oftentimes, I guess, maybe it's just me, but I often think of the map.
But there's actual criteria and some considerations that are in there that help you to, that helps the council and the city make decisions about which land to bring in.
So, for instance, you know, a potential reason, we list potential reasons why we'd bring something in.
And one of those would be, well, maybe it's economically, economically, an economic value.
This land would be economically valuable to the city to have in.
Maybe it helps us make some transportation connections and add some land that has some strategic value.
We also identify in there some state code issues that we need to be aware of,
like if we're bumping up against Camp Williams or an airport, we might remind the user of the annexation plan that,
hey, you need to be looking out for Camp Williams if you're going to annex land.
There's some additional considerations that need to be evaluated.
Also, you know, our city is unique.
And so we've identified a handful of issues that need to be considered, evaluated when we go through an annexation policy plan.
Remember, we have six areas and, or six current areas.
And then area one to the, area one and two are both to the south.
You can see that, I think this is good land for energy development and utility and transportation, corridor preservation.
And then area three is a little piece that may be valuable for open space and recreation.
Area four and five are, could be economic, land that could be very important for economic development, transportation connections.
Five, similar thing, but there may be some recreation opportunities there.
And six is land that may be important for recreation and open space.
So most of this land's already been, a lot of it's been in our annexation plan for a while.
Areas two and three, one, two, and three were, are new as of the end of last year.
And then, of course, area seven is this new area that we propose.
Like area one, it gives you access to, some more access to Utah Lake.
But it also, there, there's some mineral deposits on area seven that are, that are valuable.
And we, we have some potential property owners who are willing to, to work with us a little bit to, to, to maybe make that worth bringing into the city.
So, obviously, uh, when you bring something in, there's benefits, you know, maybe there's some strategic value to bringing seven in with, with minerals.
But then there's the cost of extending infrastructure and the environmental considerations with, with being right by Utah Lake.
So, um, it's not too, we're generally not hitting, hitting, you know, you can see Fairfield's annexation plan.
We're talking clear down here.
Um, Saratoga ends just a little pat, their, their annexation plan ends a little past Pelican Point.
And then you can see Cedar Fort's not really a consideration, but, or at least they, they're, they're north and we're talking quite a way south.
So, um, this area seven, Pelican Point's over here.
So, we're still quite a ways away from, from Saratoga's boundaries.
So, just, uh, uh, it's just, just wanted to give you a heads up because we've already had, we've, we've taken, we've had an affected entity meeting, public hearing, and then we're going to take this to the planning commission again for their recommendation next week.
And then we, we plan to bring this to you July 7th and just wanted to make sure that you were aware of it and to give you a chance to give us any feedback before, um, before we come to you, uh, in a policy session.
And when you went through the document, you saw that just like, uh, the areas one through six, we give a little description of, of the area and, and why it may, you know, some of the challenges and constraints that, that come with bringing area into the land.
So, or area into the city, potentially.
So, um, you can, I've given you a document that kind of shows the, the, the, the relatively few changes to the, the existing document and just here to see if you have any feedback.
Or, um, anything you'd like to, um, staff to consider while we're working on this.
Mayor, can I just ask a question?
Are there any financial obligations of when we annex these properties into Eagle Mountain that exist today that we would be taking over that we need to consider financially or from a budget perspective?
Um, not that I'm aware of.
I mean, obviously, if they come in, then we, we have, uh, we start dealing with, uh, as they come in, I don't have that open right now.
There, obviously, there are, um, utilities and so forth that, that may come into being, but if, if, if it's land that hasn't been developed, it just stays there.
It, it, it, it starts to go through the development process before, you know, before it, uh, becomes much of a concern for us.
Like, what, what I'm thinking about is, is, uh, is Wasatch, Wing and Clay, is that currently in Eagle Mountain or is that just outside?
It's outside.
So the road that leads there, would we then take over the responsibility for maintaining that road?
That, that kind of stuff is what I'm thinking about.
We do have, uh, an arrangement on that road already, uh, kind of a joint arrangement, but, yeah, if, if, if, you know, land like that comes in, it, it, it does become more of our, it becomes our responsibility.
We could have our own port to Utah Lake.
Yeah.
It's like.
I, this may be, uh, Marcus or Evan question, but if any of this land has an RDA project on it,
does the RDA automatically transfer to us?
Do we have to enter into an interlocal agreement if that happens?
What typically happens with that?
So if there's an existing RDA with the county, then that RDA would continue to exist, but it wouldn't be with the city.
It'd be with the county.
We wouldn't necessarily have to.
We could, we could work with the property owner to incorporate, um, the incentives that were given to them by the county into, but as of yet, we're not a participant in that.
So that would have to be something that would, we'd have to affirmatively amend.
Okay.
Any other questions?
Is there, I guess maybe I just wanted to state to you that this is the annexation policy plan of where we intend to go in the future,
but an actual annexation itself typically would have an annexation agreement by which you would, you know, have a little bit more control and stipulate and how you apply zoning and all that type of thing.
All that could come at a later date.
This really is just the plan.
Right.
Exactly.
Okay.
Thanks, Brandon.
While you're up there, we can roll on to the next one of the transition lines in the ag zone.
Yep.
I'm ready to go.
So a few weeks ago, um, we had WSP and Rocky Mountain, uh, representatives from Rocky Mountain.
They were looking at the, uh, they, they continue to evaluate this transmission, uh, transmission project from Spanish fork Canyon, uh, over to the Mercer substation down by meta.
And, uh, and so they came in and just kind of gave us an update of where that's at.
Um, you can see on the map that, uh, they, they do have this blue lines, kind of their preferred route and I'll, I'll zoom in here now so you can get a little better look at that.
They, they have, I think there's like, what is it, uh, uh, uh, three other, uh, um, alignment, uh, other alignments that they could go with, but this is their preferred alignment.
And so what we noticed, uh, here, here's a little bit better, here, here's their preferred alignment right here and you can see it on a parcel map and, and kind of in comparison to, uh, to this is our ag, this is our ag zoning down in that same area.
So, um, so we, a lot of this land, a lot of this land where this will come through is, uh, is ag.
So it looks like that's probably not even in the city, but as it comes, enters into this part, into this land right here, it's, it's ag.
And that creates a little bit of a challenge or a lot of a challenge because, um, our current ag zone doesn't allow for, it allows for public and private utilities.
But if you look at the definition of utilities, it, uh, it doesn't mention anything about electrical transmission.
And, and so, um, we, we're here to just kind of let you know about this issue, uh, that we don't have an, a lot.
We don't have an ability to allow this transmission line through, uh, through our city in this area to get over to the substation because we're, transmission lines aren't allowed in the ag zone.
So, um, I noticed, let me show you this.
We don't allow transmission zones specifically in too many areas.
This is, this is all I could find.
We allow electrical substations and power transmission lines in the LMD, the MEC, and the office, or actually, excuse me, just the LMD zone, uh, by special use.
So, we, we, we are, we've got data centers, they need power.
We just have a little bit of a hiccup in our code.
Um, and I know this issue's come up before and just wanted to, to bring that before the council to, to, uh, discuss this with you and see what we can do to, uh, help facilitate the completion of, uh, to, to help facilitate this transmission line, bringing power to the data centers.
So, what, what would you propose, are you proposing like a transit, transmission line overlay, or what, what are you proposing?
Um, I am looking for, I'm open to suggestions.
I think a transmission line is something we've considered.
Um, we could also, rather than make a new zone, we could just add some additional standards to the, to the, we could just make it a special use.
In, um, let me open this up here.
We can make it a special use in the, uh, in the ag zone and then add some additional requirements.
This is, this is kind of our junk drawer code, our junk drawer chapter, where we've got all kinds of, uh, spare codes and all kinds of things.
But we could add some additional requirements to kind of beef, beef, beef up that, uh, beef up the, uh, um, requirements and, and, uh, kind of the restrictions on that use.
So that's, that's kind of where I'd like, I personally like the most simple solution possible.
Um, and overlays, we can look at an overlay, but I'd really proud, probably prefer to just add some standards to the, to 1775 to our special, special uses chapter.
That makes sense.
I think we're probably going to have more of this.
I was really excited to see this, that, uh, you know, the ability to create power, it's the substations that we're lacking.
Yeah.
The ability to distribute power.
So, I think I'd support adding to the junk drawer.
My question stems from property tax.
If, is, does our property tax collection change depending upon whether or not these power lines are in ag or some other zoning?
Does it, do we get less property tax if it's an ag?
Is that the actual use?
Is that just the base use and that's why it's ag or is there actual agricultural uses being used underneath and around these transition lines?
That'd be my assumption, but I would really want to check with, with, uh, my neighbor, Diana Garcia, who runs, uh, kind of the green belt tax, uh, program for the county.
I, I, I'm not aware that, that, that, that messes up that, that ability to have green belt, but, um, that's something we'd have to explore a little further.
Yeah.
I, I think I just want to better understand the ramifications financially for us as a city.
Um, if we don't have to provide any services like normal agricultural land use, then it's probably okay.
But if there's additional things that we have to provide as a city and eggs being used for the junk drawer principle, then I want to look at that and make sure that we're zoning it the most appropriate zone for that land use.
You can accomplish it with a special use.
That's the easiest way to deal with this.
Yeah.
Okay.
But my question on the special use is what's our ability to deny in areas that we don't want it?
Because I think if the special use goes in there, there's certain criteria.
If they meet the criteria, we can't deny it.
So it's effectively just adding it in there.
Right.
If they meet the criteria, that, that is the downside to, to adding it as a special use.
The, the overlay, that's always, that's, that's kind of the thing with zones in any situation.
A zone gives you, if you have the ability to approve a zone, it gives you the right, uh, gives you an extra chance to look at it before it goes in.
So an overlay does give you more protection.
My concern is exactly what Councilman Whiting just addressed.
And I'm just wondering why we can't address this through a DA.
I mean, that gives the city council very strict parameters that they can put in place of location, time, scale, all of that.
And to me, that makes the most sense.
So why not put that in the special use then?
But this can be granted by development agreement.
Uh, I think that's the mechanism that allows us to.
So if Rocky Mountain Power is, is putting up transmission lines, they're not going to agree to a development agreement.
That's really just not how they work.
So, so how, so how do we, how do we, how do we get something like that in place?
I mean, they're going to tell you, these are what we want.
If you want the transmission lines and there can be some room, well, room for negotiation, but that's really it.
Like if the zoning doesn't allow it, then it doesn't allow it.
That's, they're not going to like give concessions to the city.
That's not my experience with Rocky Mountain Power anyways.
Can we, can we create a specific zone that would allow just that period?
I mean, that was a council member Hughish's first suggestion.
Well, he's talking about an overlay.
I'm talking about a specific zone.
So they've got to come and get a zoning designation change to be able to put it in.
Well, typically they're going to get an easement, right?
They're not going to buy the property in a few simple.
That's right.
I think the overlay may be cleaner because you could just put the overlay exactly where you want it.
They're still going to have an easement.
That's why I said the special use makes the most sense.
You can still deal with this in a contract, Marcus.
Let's have to set the parameters of what that is.
And maybe they're going to say this, this, this, and this have to be in there.
And maybe that's the way that is.
But you can also be restrictive in saying we're not going to allow you to do, you know, the 100-foot transmission lines right down the middle of this corner.
Yeah, well, that's what we would put in the special use standards, right?
So you'd say, you know, it's proximity to residential zoning, you know, height of the lines, things like that could be put into the special use standards.
So you don't have to do it ad hoc every time.
Yeah.
I would prefer just bracket it.
I think we can do that or we don't want it there at all.
I mean, that's the decision, right?
Put the brackets in place or say we don't have access.
Yeah, I mean, I think that was the suggestion was to put standards in place that we can live with.
So that way, if people are, if they're putting it in, you know, so there's certain areas of town that's usually going to be related to proximity to existing residential.
I mean, maybe there are other reasons, proximity to other types of uses like schools or something that might be an issue.
But I think that's, you know, those kinds of standards can be put in a special use code.
Do you know what the standard, I mean, I think you want to have at least some distance, especially if you're dealing with the large overhead lines from houses.
And I know that there's some cities that let them literally go right over the top of the houses.
My brother lives next to some in Bluffdale, which is crazy to me.
But I think that's probably the main concern is to just.
I mean, I will tell you that there were existing transmission lines running through what is now the street that my house is on and run through the park across the street from my house.
It's, I mean, nobody seems to think it's a big deal.
So, I mean, as far as a safety concern, you know, aesthetically sure.
Yeah, I mean, they run through Alpine homes in Lehigh.
I mean, every set of those I've dealt with, people trying to buy the houses or sell the houses with that.
So, they do exist.
The question is, what do we care about?
What is it that we're trying to prevent?
What is it that we're trying to bracket?
Maybe that's, maybe get some feedback from people who feel strongly about it not being this or not being that.
We put that into special use, right?
Because even if you do an overlay, it's, you're going to have to apply it somewhere.
And they're going to come in and say, we want to put it right here.
And you're going to be like, I don't want it there.
And they'll ask for the overlay zone.
It's better just to bracket it and say where you want it.
So, well, wouldn't the overlay do that, though?
That's an after-the-fact thing, though.
The overlay, unless you're applying it and saying this is the place where transmission lines can go,
they're going to be coming in and asking for the overlay zone of where they want to put it.
So, either you're going to have to make the decision beforehand,
or you might as well just zone it at that point and say,
transmission lines can go through this corridor that we've created through the city,
but we're not going to allow them to go anywhere else.
I think part of the problem with that is I don't have a crystal ball to understand
where transmission lines might need to go throughout the city, right?
Long term.
So, that, for me, is why the overlay makes a lot more sense
because it's going to require a council decision to say,
yes, we're going to apply the overlay zone here.
I think those special standards should apply and should be part of that overlay zone.
And I guess the concern that I have is maybe there needs to be a tiered approach
because we might want some big transmission lines on the south end of the city
to support the data center.
We certainly don't want them on some of the foothills or some of those areas that we're trying to preserve
just for some unique, perhaps, residential or even commercial uses.
So, I think that's where we need to be contemplative about this.
Do you have other cities' codes related to this that you've looked at?
Not yet.
No.
I think that might be a good starting point.
Let's see what other people are doing.
I know Lehigh has them.
Bluffdale has them.
West Valley has them.
Basically, West Jordan.
I think Harriman.
So, you could pretty much follow that corridor.
Somebody's going to have something where they're addressing, even just in a standard.
Maybe there's not a zone in there.
Maybe that's a starting point for us to take a look at.
Yeah.
We'll definitely research all that.
But I think I would say this, Brandon.
And I appreciate that you brought this to our attention because I, for one, at least, am willing and open to helping find a solution
so that we can get that transmission line to that substation.
I want that to be clear.
I will.
Sorry.
I really like the idea of the overlay, specifically because of the public noticing requirements
and the public hearing that would have to take place when they come to request that.
And I think, to everyone's point, letting the public weigh in on that, I think, is important.
It gives us an awareness of how it's going to impact them.
And my other question was, we have those transmission lines that go through the ranches at Liberty Farms,
and then it comes over Lake Mountain, and then we have the ones that are at Woodhaven.
Would the ones that we're considering for the Mercer substation be larger or smaller than those?
On their website, they gave a range for how large those would be,
and it was somewhere in the neighborhood of, yeah, they gave a range.
I think it was like 90 to 120.
I'm trying to remember.
Does anyone know off the top of their head how tall some of those other ones are that we have going through?
This is a major transmission line.
It's the exact same thing as the other lines that go through the high voltage.
So, like, the Woodhaven one and, like, maybe not Woodhaven, but for sure the Liberty Farms ones.
The ones that go down Lake Mountain.
Lake Mountain, yeah.
Like, and the thing is, is I don't know that we had any say about where those were going.
We just developed around them after the fact, and we're mindful of that.
And our code specifically says that you can't have structures under power corridors.
So, like, I think in a lot of ways that is a protection for us.
But I still think the best way to handle it is the overlay, because it does have that public hearing process.
So, my last question is, I know that along Lake Mountain Road, on the west side of it, we already have power lines going.
So, we can't run these new power lines close to those?
It's possible we could look at that, but they, I think they're looking for the most expeditious route, and they're only entering in.
They're entering basically right through there.
Is there any other questions?
Go ahead.
So, what you're saying is they're just going to come in two of those blocks.
Are those 160-acre blocks?
Those look like sections to me.
Yeah.
So, um, 160 acres.
Right, exactly.
But I'll take that information.
I'll research what other cities are doing.
Generally, is there, I'm getting the sense that the council would prefer an overlay.
Is that what I'm hearing?
I'm seeing foreheads nodding.
Yes.
If that's the case, then I can pursue that and look at what other cities are doing.
I'll bring some options, but I'll be leaning towards an overlay, it looks like.
So, try, we like simple solutions.
I'll try to make it fairly simple while respecting the idea that it's an overlay.
One last really quick question, because I have a feeling residents are going to want to know this.
Sometimes people think that our rates are going to want to know this.
Sometimes people think that our rates are going up because these transmission lines are going in to take care of specific large-use customers.
If there's any information that we as a city can obtain and share with our residents down the road about whether or not that's a reality or if that's just the rumor that's going around, I think that would be useful information for us to share with our residents.
I'll, yes, and we can, what we can do is I can work with our communication team and put this website out.
The other thing I'll let you know is we do have some representatives from WSP and Rocky Mountain that are likely watching us right now.
And I can, I know that I told them I was going to come and talk to you.
So, they'll be able to provide me some additional information as well, but we'll help to get the word out.
All right.
Thank you.
The next discussion, 1C, is the Sage Valley Community Entrance Sign.
Mr. Stephen Lemons has some information.
All right.
So, we received an application at the beginning of the year from the Sage Valley community wanting to put in a community entrance sign similar to what you see in, I'd say, the majority of neighborhoods here in the city, especially in the ranches.
It says it's a fairly uniform sign there, the proposals to put it between what used to be airport or airport road there and the current or the new alignment.
So, it says going to be right here with this orange rectangle.
So, the intersection of airport road and Whelan drive.
This is what was provided by the applicant, so put it right there outside of would miss the storm light or the storm drain here outside of the site triangle.
This is all we've gotten so far from the applicant is these mock-up drawings of what it would look like, the sizes.
The code doesn't really speak to what the size has to be.
All it says is that there has to be an agreement with the city to put it on city property.
It has to be leased.
But outside of that, there's no specific thing.
So, really, the recommendations from staff is we just want to get feedback from the council.
Is that something the council is willing to pursue, what they want to see in an agreement.
So, we take it back to the applicant and go forward with that.
Just to add some color, I mentioned that this was going to be on the agenda, and I'll have to recuse myself from any vote here because this is my neighborhood.
I think I have to recuse myself.
Maybe I don't.
I don't benefit.
It's just for the neighborhood.
It's a discussion, anyway.
It's a discussion.
We're not voting on anything.
So, back before I moved into this neighborhood, Patterson, part of their punch list from the city was to create a monument sign.
Again, there was one that was built at one point.
That was before I moved in.
And my understanding is when the utilities came in for another part of the neighborhood, that monument sign was removed.
So, I don't know when monument signs are created, if they're given to the city to kind of maintain or manage.
But that monument sign was not ever replaced.
So, I just wanted to add that for some context for the council.
And I have a neighbor that has the original MDA, the punch list.
He's got all the documentation, which I don't know if you've seen any of that.
But there was once upon a time a sign.
It was removed.
It hasn't been added back.
So, I think the question is, my question is, is there a responsibility on the city's part, if that was a city sign, to replace it?
And if so, is there a budget for that?
The neighborhood's willing to build the sign.
They have the technical abilities to do that.
The cost to build it is about $3,500 in materials.
In general, to answer that question, the city's been taking those out because they've been in the right-of-ways.
Like, for instance, in Cedar Pass Ranch, they're right in the middle of the road.
And as we're widening the roads, we're taking them out and not replacing them.
Throughout the city, that's been the case.
When we were a lot smaller, maybe they worked.
But we've taken out multiple monument signs, mostly throughout the ranches.
That's where they were prominent.
And they're not being replaced.
I would say if they want them, you're an HOA, right?
We're not.
Well, maybe somebody's personal property can be put on that.
If you put it in the right-of-way, there's a good chance it'll be taken down again, it sounds like.
The location.
Oh.
Can you pull the map back up what's being considered?
So that's the sidewalk that goes up to the middle school.
And I don't know that anything would be developed there.
There's just a storm drain in that area right now.
Zach, one of the things that I, when we were reviewing this as a staff, you'll see the little sidewalk right here.
I'm pointing on the other side.
And then there's a little yellow line right there.
So this triangle is city property as well, but less likely to have right-of-way.
This portion, that right-of-way, could go all the way to that yellow line.
So if the council was interested, I would at least propose, if you don't want it taken out, you know, a few feet further north is less likely to be impacted.
But right where that sidewalk is and that radius is part of what could be future road design or maybe not.
You're saying, oh, to move it north?
Yeah.
I mean, on this side, you can see a little bit better.
Just a few more feet from here is there.
This is less likely to be impacted than here.
If the council chooses to do something like this, and a lease would still be part of that, however this proceeds.
But in general, a lot of the monument signs have been removed and not replaced.
I'm supportive of the monument signs.
It creates a sense of place, a sense of arrival, a sense of home, a sense of ownership.
I think we shouldn't be removing them.
Obviously, if we need to move them, that's one thing.
But removing them, I don't think we should do.
I think we should have them.
And I'm in favor of Sage Valley doing this.
And I'll speak in here.
I mean, it sounds like the residents would be willing to take the financial burden on themselves.
That's what I'm hearing you say, Zach.
Yes.
Is that right?
Yep.
So really, they're just asking the city for permission to be able to locate it on city property.
Right.
And that would require some sort of an agreement.
I think that's what staff is saying their recommendation is that we consider that.
And I'm certainly open to that.
I mean, we have to talk about if and when it needs to be removed, and there's a likelihood that that could happen at some point in time.
I think we need to be realistic enough to know that that road's going to expand, it's going to get bigger, and that right-of-way is likely to change.
Maybe not in my lifetime, but probably in yours, Zach.
So assuming we're both still around for a while.
But I'm open to that, especially if the residents are willing to take this project on themselves.
I think if it put a burden on the city's finances, I might feel differently.
But where the residents are saying, look, we're willing to come and put some sweat equity in this, it's important to us.
I agree with what Councilmember Whiting said.
It does create a sense of place.
And I'm supportive also of what the mayor said.
I understand why we're taking them out of the middle of those road networks.
And it's very difficult to get any type of vehicle, a truck and a trailer, and anything bigger than that becomes very, very difficult.
And so would I like to see those relocated?
The answer is yes, but it's not been practical in those areas where they moved.
What would the maintenance entail, and would that be something that the neighborhood takes on by agreement or the city would have some responsibility for?
Do you know about that?
I think the neighborhood would, I can't speak for future neighbors, but those that are there today would maintain it.
It would be made out of steel and rock, cement, so I don't think there would be much maintenance.
There is a post hole in the back of the sign for a flagpole.
So it would be maintained by the neighborhood.
I think my point of reference when I ask about maintenance is in the ranches, almost all of those neighborhoods got some sort of monument sign that was steel, rock, cement.
And there's probably not a lot of maintenance, but after a while the letters on the monument start to look shabby.
And I think because the ranch's HOA was dissolved, the cities had to take on that maintenance.
And I think if the neighbors in those neighborhoods knew what they could do to maintain it, they probably would step up and do it.
But it's just clear expectations of who's supposed to do what with it, I think is important.
And I think if we agree to do this as a city, I think we'll see more neighborhoods wanting to do something like that because, to Council Member Whiting's point, it does create a sense of place.
It does create that kind of, like, ownership of something.
So I'm in favor of the idea.
I just want to make sure all of our I's are dotted and our T's are crossed.
So you raise a couple of really good points, Council Member Clark.
And so one of the things I'm sitting here thinking about is the continuity of design.
Are some going to have flagpoles and some aren't?
Are they going to be out of steel letters, stainless steel letters?
Are they going to be painted fluorescent pink?
What are they going to look like?
Depends on the neighborhood.
And so I think that if we're thinking about something like this, I think we should write and create some standards so that there's some continuity in the design and in the application of that citywide.
We have standards for monument signs already, so I think it would probably just have to follow that.
And maybe we look at that and tighten it up and make sure that applies.
And the next thing that went through my head as you were speaking is what happens when a car hits this?
Who's going to take care of that?
Who's going to bear the liability of?
Existing city code would require that the applicant take on that burden of maintenance, of basement, liability, indemnification.
The problem really becomes, and it would be a lease of the city's property.
So who's going to lease it?
One individual homeowner?
Or is it going to be, you don't have a homeowner's association.
So, you know.
It would be the applicant.
Okay.
So that's a pretty heavy lift.
You know, I don't know that I would sign that.
And so the problem becomes, of course, what happens when somebody moves.
I mean, we can say, look, you got to either sign the lease or we're taking it out.
I don't know how realistic that is, to be honest, from the city's perspective.
So in neighborhoods today, I mean, there's a lot of these monument signs throughout the ranches.
Each one of those monument signs, there is somebody in that neighborhood that currently has a legal financial responsibility?
My suspicion is that that was part of a common area and the HOA at the time.
And now there's no HOA, so the city owns the signs.
So, like, a rival, I think they have an entrance sign?
Yeah, they may have it on their property, not on city property.
I don't know that for sure.
So, for instance, what you wouldn't need is if you decided to put it, you know, like right here on private property, right here on private property, you know, outside of the city property.
That would, those are all on private property.
At least that's what he's, yeah.
Honestly, that's a safer bet, Council Member Hewish, from my perspective, is to talk to those two neighbors and see if they're willing to let you construct a sign on either of those spots.
That removes a bunch of concerns that are going to be raised.
I mean, I see you looking at that, and I think that part of the dedication from the developer was that they put the signs in.
They were responsible to build them, to install them, to dedicate them to either the HOA or the city, whichever the course was.
I mean, I'm trying to think of a monument sign that's come to us in my term, and off the top of my head, I'm not thinking of one.
I wasn't here.
I was on planning commission.
I'm not taking the heat for the Overland sign.
So I think, and I don't want to speak for the applicant specifically, but I think the idea is that the neighborhood would build a monument sign that would add to the culture of the city, of the neighborhood.
When you enter Airport Road, there would be a nice monument sign that adds value to the city, it adds appeal.
So as a council, maybe, is that something that we want as a city?
Do we want to have that exist?
Oh, sorry.
I don't think I would put that on one person to be financially responsible.
I think it would be something that the neighborhood could build to code, engineered, all of that.
The financial cost would be on the neighborhood to build it and put it up.
Something that is high quality, but ultimately the city would own it, yeah, maybe maintain it.
I think we should, well, this is my opinion.
I think we should work to find the parameters at which we're comfortable to get this to a yes, because we're looking at right now behind people's homes, land that's the cities, and getting that sold to some of the adjoining property owners, or updating that land and putting in a different trail.
We're very much in the process of beautifying our city and setting ourselves apart from other areas, and I think that this is a good step in that direction.
I don't know how all of it works out, and I'm sure there's going to be some legal considerations, and who's responsible for what, and all sorts of things.
But I think it's worth the wrestle to try to figure it out together.
And if we go through the process and the exercise of looking at it, and it just doesn't work out, fine.
But I think it's worth trying to get it to a yes.
Is there any reason we can't put it in the easement on the east side of the road?
Where's my pointer at?
So in this area over here.
That's where most of them are.
That's not right away.
That's not in an easement.
This is considered the right-of-way right here?
That's your property.
Yeah, so I'm not sure if those lines are precisely accurate.
But, yeah, anything to the outside of the homeowner's property area is not going to be an easement.
It would be part of the right-of-way.
That's not a utility easement is what you're saying?
I don't think so.
I mean, I haven't looked at this specifically.
So, I mean, you would normally click on it to determine, you know, and the county records are going to tell you who owns that property.
If it says Eagle Mountain City, then it's in the right-of-way.
If it says something else, then it's, then obviously that's not right-of-way.
It says it belongs to Eagle Mountain City.
Yeah, it's going to be part of the public right-of-way then, which is what we're talking about.
It's what they're requesting.
To me, it makes more sense to do it on the east side because there's less likely that they're going to come, start taking the front part of the lawn out.
I think on the opposite side of the road, it's a likely scenario.
What are you talking about?
It's a loop.
That's the entrance off of the airport road into their neighborhood.
Okay.
Fair enough.
But anybody that lives anywhere besides those three houses comes in and goes this way.
I've driven it.
So, it goes to these five houses, maybe.
I'm saying it's not a busy road.
I don't disagree.
Is that going to stay that way when they do the expansion, though, of SR73?
Do you know why they chose that location over the other one?
Over the house?
Oh, you mean going further north?
Up here.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, nobody drives that way.
So, everybody goes, they go straight through.
And then hook up and then connect that way.
Yeah.
So, since the road pattern changed, that gets less use further north.
Point.
Here.
Use that for point.
Where does everybody go?
Right through here.
Okay.
That's what I assumed.
I knew they used to use the other entrance, but since airport road's done, now they're using the south entrance.
So, to sum things up, our concerns are placement, maintenance, who owns the land that it's on, whether or not there would be a lease, whether or not the applicant is in charge of maintenance, or whether or not this was received as a gift to the city and the city takes it on maintenance-wise.
I don't think we can answer most of those questions.
I mean, is there anybody who's against putting it on the city property?
No.
That's the first question.
I don't have a problem with that.
Sounds like Zach doesn't.
Sounds like Craig doesn't.
Brett, where are you at?
I'm just concerned about any liability that that might bring to the city, that's all.
Oh, we already have them.
The reality is they already exist.
We have monument signs all throughout the ranches.
Yes.
Should we be creating one in this area?
That's really the question.
Do we want to create an additional liability?
That's the question I'm asking myself.
I'm not worried about that.
I mean, we already have the liability.
They're already there in droves.
So, I'm more concerned about identification of areas.
I do think that that's a benefit to be able to identify the area that you're coming to,
especially people who are trying to bring packages and things of that nature.
All of those things are helpful for directions.
I think less impactful on the east side of the road is my opinion.
I'd say maybe they'd be smarter to work between those two houses
and see if they can get free council members to agree to put them where those white rocks are,
somewhere in that area.
That makes more sense to me than putting it across the street.
Where that's not the entrance to the neighborhood.
It sounds like there used to be a sign there that the city would have had liability for.
It got a monument there and it got removed.
So, we're just adding back something the city previously already agreed to take liability for.
So, I'm fine with another monument going back up there.
There was one there to begin with.
I'm flexible as to the location, whether it's east or west, frankly.
And I would also add, if our monument standards don't allow flags,
I am supportive that a flag could be added to the monument.
So, just a couple things to point out.
Not to your opinion.
I don't care about your opinion.
But it wasn't the city's.
It was most likely on an HOA or private property or whatever when that got expanded.
So, not necessarily.
Also, if it's on city land and it is an American flag, is it lit?
And if it's lit, who's carrying the burden for that electricity?
Is that city?
And who's going to replace the flag?
So, all of those questions, right?
I think you could do solar.
I don't think it would cost anything.
But an American flag, I should have clarified.
Yes, an American flag only.
Yeah.
And most of the stand-up flags that you put in a post, they come with a solar top.
So, they project down on.
There's quite a few vets in our neighborhood.
We'd make sure that would be lit up.
Okay.
Go ahead.
Do you feel like you've got the direction?
Obviously, there's some questions that need to be asked to the applicant.
Do you feel like you have at least some beneficial questions to ask?
I think I have enough direction.
I'm going to ask Marcus because you're going to be the one right.
My concern is really, like, is the city wanting to entertain a lease agreement?
Or is the city wanting to own it?
I would think so.
Because if they build it at their expense and install it and we want to own it just to,
not put that burden on one individual, then we should say that now.
Otherwise, the code says that their code allows for somebody to lease property from the city
and that would be an ongoing financial burden for them.
If we're going to do it, then the city owns it.
Like, if they're going to pay for it and dedicate it to the city,
my preference would be that the city owns it.
Yeah, I'm kind of looking at it as a gift to the city,
much like other things have been gifted to the city,
statues and different types of monuments and whatnot.
So I think once it's on our property, we take ownership of it and maintain it.
Agreed.
I think if we're going to do it, that that's the only way to really do it for it.
Because then the city controls what happens to it.
If it needs to be moved, it needs to be removed.
It needs to be maintained, all of the above.
So if that's where the council is going to land,
I think that's probably a better option than trying to put that burden on one individual.
I just think that if that's the decision,
the council needs to be very clear with the applicant
that there's no guarantee that sign stays there.
Right.
Okay.
Last comment so we can roll on.
Does the council have any recommendation on the current location,
move it further, a little bit further north?
I think you have a better chance of not having it be taken down.
Get moved again?
Yeah.
Do you feel okay with that, Stephen, talking to the applicant about location?
Okay.
And then I would just say, let's take a look at what the code is with entry monuments
and just make sure, one, that the proposed one is congruent with that,
but then, two, is there anything in our code that needs to be tightened up?
Because I do think that there will be other neighborhoods that want to do this
as a gift to the city, and we should figure it out now,
and you guys can be the guinea pig.
All right.
Thanks, Stephen.
I think we better roll on.
Does that cover that?
Okay.
And I know you had a comment a minute ago.
I don't know if I got to you.
You changed your mind?
I was covered.
Okay.
Perfect.
Then I'll just turn it to you on the next item anyway and say,
is there any items?
I don't think I have anything.
I sent a kind of a detailed email out to the council as I was flying out of town.
I just appreciate the council and the staff for filling in for me the last couple days,
and I think that's all I had unless the council has questions.
Mayor, can we ask that the annexation plan presentation be added either to our packet
or the minute so the images are available with the record?
Sure.
Is that okay?
Okay.
Thank you.
Can you take care of that, Brandon?
Yeah, absolutely.
Work with Lacey.
All right.
Let's move on to some of our agenda review.
Some of this, I think we can breeze through pretty quickly.
Item 7A, fire restrictions.
It's information only.
Is there any questions on?
Mayor, we did have a resident reach out and ask us if there's any way to further tighten up
the fireworks map within the city, in particular, on some of those areas to the south.
I just don't know what the process would be to do that at this point in the game.
So I'm just asking questions.
I can let Marcus weigh in, but it's up to the council.
I think the fireworks map has to be set in place by the beginning of May.
So for this year, there's nothing else that we can do.
It would be moving forward.
The council can do further restrictions, though, right?
That's my understanding.
I think HOAs can certainly go beyond the city's requirements.
Yeah, I think ultimately the state has put restrictions on us about deadlines so that those can be in place well in advance of the fourth.
Yeah, and I'm not trying to lay that on anybody.
I'm just asking the question.
The residents reached out and expressed some concerns.
Yeah, if they're in an HOA, HOAs can add additional restrictions.
Most HOAs have a process of changing their rules so that they can do that.
Additionally, you know, that we can look at the map and tighten it up for future years.
But other than that, it's just enforcement.
And what are the penalties if someone decides that they're going to do that?
Oh, it depends on what exactly they do.
I mean, it could be anything from, you know, a Class B misdemeanor violation to you went and destroyed public infrastructure recklessly and you committed a second-degree felony.
So, I mean, it just really depends on what exactly occurs.
Okay.
Thank you.
Sorry.
Mayor, I actually think that it would be a good idea to have our legislative services team take a look at working with some of our state counterparts to fix the code, the state code, and the deadline on that.
Because it's really difficult for a city like Eagle Mountain to know in May what the conditions will magically be in June, July, August, September.
And I think that we should have more autonomy when it comes to creating safe zones in our city.
And when things are really dry or we're in the middle of a drought, we should have the ability to put a restriction on certain areas based on not emotion but evidence and expert opinion.
And I'm happy to have them look into that.
My recollection is a council can further restrict even what the fire says and kind of has that ability now anyway.
And then I think, and you'd have to correct me, this is going to be a stretch for me.
I've never done it.
But if it was a state of emergency, so an executive officer could declare some kind of a, I'm using the word.
If it was a state of emergency, then there's additional powers that, that you have for sure.
Um, I couldn't quote, you know, what the, you know, without researching into it, you know, what the, you know, how much you could do in relation to fireworks per se and in classifying a state of emergency due to drought conditions.
And that's further restricting fireworks use.
Um, but that's certainly something that we can look into.
I, Mayor, what I remember about applying it is that when we apply additional restrictions, I feel like it had to be applied to the entire city.
I think that might be right, but, but I know it's, it's available.
So, yeah.
I'll just share some of my concerns.
And one of the concerns that I have is going into this fire season, knowing that we're already dealing with drought conditions, right?
We know that everything is a tender box.
And so, I mean, my, my, my plea is, I guess, to the residents to please be careful as you're lighting fireworks, enjoy those celebrations, come participate with us at Corey B ride.
Um, but be careful where you're doing those.
I live in an area that's restricted and every single year, every single year without fail, several of my neighbors are lighting off big.
Fireworks.
And it makes me hyper nervous.
And I think, well, what's the penalty?
Because to date, the penalty has been nothing.
And, uh, and I think it just takes one, one accident, uh, that creates all kinds of, all kinds of issues.
And the other concern that I have is just with our water situation.
I mean, if, if UFA has got to fight fires in Eagle Mountain and wildland fires, um, you're going to see our water situation get significantly worse as those resources are.
We're drawn upon to fight a wildland fire.
So I just, I think, I think we need to be careful about the way we evaluate it.
And I think that we need to hold one another accountable as neighbors, friends, and residents regarding fire restrictions.
And, and just the, the, the way that we interact with, uh, with our community at that level.
So one of the other things that is part of this, and I've just been waiting, uh, I think I had mentioned to everybody, I forget where we're at, but, uh, Saratoga specifically with four fires in five days had asked that we join with them in, in a letter to the governor.
To, to, to implement stage one fire restrictions specifically on Lake mountain.
Uh, the governor did sign an order and I was going to, I think you were in the text message.
Have you read the stage one?
If you're interested, if not, I read a lot today.
So you're going to read this then.
Okay.
So when we get to seven, eight in the public meeting, I'll, I'll call you up.
Not necessarily now at the seven o'clock hour, uh, but this is, we'll go through this whole thing.
It's the, it's pretty standard stage one fire restrictions.
So we will, and that's on state lands that is not within the city boundaries.
So I just want to be clear and, uh, yeah, Lake mountain, all of that.
So we'll cover that in a minute.
Any other questions on the fire restrictions?
Okay.
Uh, next we will go on to 10 a harmony, a, a D B plus.
Flat 13 into warranty.
Any questions there?
Okay.
Traffic signal.
Um, uh, yeah, the change order.
And that one, I think wraps this one up.
That was, um, was it David that had that one?
Any questions for David?
I think we've talked about this one before.
We're good.
Okay.
Um, let's see.
12 a was the minutes.
Any corrections?
Nothing.
13 a is the consolidated fee schedule.
Aaron is here to speak to that.
If there's any questions, not seeing any resolution of Eagle mountain city, approving the recreational
sports sponsorship program.
And I think this one does have a presentation.
Is that right?
Jesse Southworth's here from the, um, community services board to address this issue.
So it's, um, it's a sponsorship, uh, policy that, well, Charlotte's here as well, but, um, Jesse's ready to speak on it.
Um, it's the sponsor said policy you heard about, you gave us direction and the board went back and reviewed it, made a recommendation.
Um, and then, um, Jesse went back and created, uh, the policy document and, uh, reviewed that with me mostly.
And then the board has seen that as well, um, um, over email and, and we're here to, to present that.
So, so, so I know there are some questions that I've heard.
Uh, we'll invite Jesse to come up maybe.
I think the, the presentation was in the packet or no.
It's just the policy itself.
So it's not really a presentation.
We'll, we'll, uh, go ahead with the presentation, whatever it is, and then ask questions after, if that's okay.
That way, cause it might answer some of the questions.
I don't have a presentation.
I just have the policy.
Oh, okay.
And that is in a packet.
So if that's the case, then you're open to questions.
Yes.
Okay.
So I had a few questions.
So is it possible to have more than one logo per Jersey?
Are you limiting it to, okay.
Four logos per Jersey.
Yes.
Okay.
There'll be one, the sleeves and then one on the front and one in the back.
And then pricing, it didn't appear to be delineated by sport.
No.
So, and the reason why I bring that up is some sports like soccer have way more participants than some of the other sports.
And so if there's a sponsorship fee for soccer, it seems like that that fee should be greater than a fee for.
Or some of the other sports that don't have as many participants.
So as it is now, it would just be a crop, like it would be one fee and it would go on all the jerseys.
Oh, it would go on all the jerseys, all the sports.
That, except for junior jazz and hockey.
Right.
Okay.
That makes more sense then.
Cause, all right.
That makes, that, that clears up my question.
Okay.
I, I just want to say that I really liked how it was put together and I really liked that the, the scholarship aspect of it.
Cause there are kids within our community that can't afford to pay, play these sports.
And it's a great way to have local businesses help support them playing in it.
And I think that's a good use of government time.
So I was just going to ask on a section 7.2, where it talks about a seven business day appeal window for a denied sponsor is, is that long enough?
Should it be 14 days?
That's up to you guys.
I mean, I think we, we went over just cause when you make everything take a really long time, we only have a certain amount of time from getting the sponsorship applications to being able to, um, get the jerseys and everything and make sure we have enough time.
But if you want it to be longer, I'm open to that.
That was any thoughts from the council?
Remind me who's, who's evaluating the, like the dispute.
I think it goes to the, is it the community services board?
Yeah.
And staff.
And I think the, like it would, I'm sorry.
I have to remember exactly what we wrote in here.
Final city action.
It's the community services board and the manager.
Oh yes.
But then they'd appeal, if there's any appeal that they need to do, it'd go to the city manager.
So can I bring something maybe to the attention?
And this is something I've dealt with like youth council and other, uh, groups as they fundraise and do things that I've heard these questions.
And so that's why I'm asking for direction.
Uh, when this sponsorship is collected, it goes into the general fund and unless it gets reallocated back to the program or whatever, it's literally just into the general fund.
Um, so what is the purpose of the sponsorship and what did we want to do with it?
Um, like for instance, I've heard people say, if we're going to do this, I want to make sure that it goes to the kids that are playing the sports, uh, that it helps reduce fees or things like that.
But we can't allocate it out of a general fund unless we know how much it is.
And so, so it becomes a whole budget process.
So what I'm asking is if these funds are collected, are they set aside specifically for grants and is it addressed?
And I don't remember it being addressed.
So I wanted you to give direction on that.
Yeah, I think in my mind, kind of like we're addressing public safety.
That's right, man.
Oh, go ahead.
It's already in there.
So that's actually one of the things I wanted to talk about.
Yes.
So it's, it's item six, uh, use of sponsorship funds.
And I'm actually against using those funds for equipment, supplies, fields and facilities, certifying coaches and referees and administrative costs.
Cause you will soak it all up with that and it'll never even see the intended purpose, which is supposed to go and provide a cost effective recreation program for everybody to participate in.
That's what it should be for anything else.
Personally, I'm not in, I'm not in favor of doing a sponsorship for, and I'm going to tell you that to be honest.
With you, I think that when people are, uh, wanting to sponsor, they're looking for it to be beneficial to the kids directly.
And all of these things are maintenance and administrative in nature.
I think we should be funding that out of our regular funds.
Sponsorship things should be going directly to the kids in my opinion.
The other question too, I'm, I'm not sure how I feel about giving over all of the oversight to, um, the, uh,
staff and to the, uh, to the board.
Some of those things where money is involved in that, I feel like that oversight should have, uh, council oversight over that still.
Um, I had it marked, but it didn't over, I had it marked with some notes and when I pulled it up, it didn't pull that over.
So I can't remember exactly where that part was, but it talks about a lot of the decisions being made by the board and the recreation manager.
Uh, they make the decision and then move forward with it.
But once funds have been acquired, I think there needs to be some oversight by the elected officials.
Can I address the, the use of the sponsorship funds?
Wouldn't the maintenance be also like having, maintaining all of that work to improve this work?
We have a parks department with a budget and they should be functioning underneath the parks department in my opinion.
We shouldn't be trying to pay for striping of fields, mowing lawns, weeding, fertilizing out of a recreation budget.
What about the equipment for like soccer?
Uh, I think there's a first time fee for that, that we've already funded.
Okay.
I think that if we feel like that we don't have enough, we can absolutely allocate more money to the recreation program from our fund.
Um, this is my opinion.
I think that that way it keeps it very clear what the money is being used for, that it is directly going to the participants and their ability to be able to, to play at a certain, um, entry level, uh, amount of money.
That everybody can afford.
I think to your question, um, if they fund players, sponsors, uh, scholarships and registration assistance, that $50 or $100 that would normally be paid by that kid is going to go into the fund to pay for things like the maintenance and whatnot.
It's just not earmarked specifically to maintenance.
It's earmarked to follow the kid that's in the program.
So in effect, it's doing the lower bullet points, but the way that we're allocating it is that the money follows the kids that are in the program.
And I think I understand the intent of what he's talking about.
It's that we don't want the program to become dependent on the sponsorship dollars that the, if the sponsorships ever went away or if the policy changed, the program would be able to move forward and continue.
Um, so I think it's still does what you're proposing.
We just need to clean up those bullet points and it would take care of it.
So what should it say?
I think that it would just be...
I'm suggesting removing those from that.
I'm not...
Maybe I wasn't clear.
I want to remove the maintenance of equipment, supplies, playing fields and facilities, training and certifying coaches and referees.
Right.
And it's all under six.
So basically the first two bullets stay and the last bullet stay.
Everything in between doesn't.
Yeah.
And that's basically what I...
The reason for that is the fees should be taking care of your referees.
That's what they're there for.
They're not for fields.
Um, and if we are, have field supervisors, they're employees of ours.
We're paying for them out of a different fund.
Okay.
So you would keep training and certifying coaches and referees.
That doesn't need to be in there.
That's, that's a responsibility of the recreation department.
Again, we want this to be something that goes directly to the kids.
I have the same trepidations about the way they do things in the school system too.
The money never seems to get to the students.
By the time it's been filtered through all the administrative people, it never even got
to the point of why that money was there in the first place.
Can I ask you to, just for clarity's sake, you continue to say we, and I'm not sure that
that's the consensus.
Is that you or is that for sure we, we want it to go to the kids?
It's a suggestion.
No, that's what I'm saying.
When you say we should.
No, you have to get everybody else to agree to that.
I'm saying we should.
Not me, because it's not my decision.
No, but I was, you're saying it as if it's the...
I said we should, and I said I would like to see those removed.
So I'm looking for consensus.
That's why I'm asking the question.
Yeah, everybody else gets the chance to weigh in on it, but I don't make any decisions.
That's why I said we should.
I was clear about that.
Sorry, what I heard is we want.
I didn't hear we should.
I heard we want, and so that was speaking for the body, and so I'm clarifying that is
that a consensus.
I heard the word want.
I apologize.
I'm good with removing purchase and maintain, maintain and improve, train and certify, and
cover administrative costs and keeping bullet points one, two, and whatever the last one
is, because like I said, all of those ones that we're removing do inherently receive funds,
but it's through per participant at a time, and the funds for sponsorship follow the participants
instead of creating independence on the sponsorships for the programs to exist.
Yeah, I think there's consensus.
It would keep the cost low for the participants.
Yep.
Could I make two suggestions?
One, maybe have an additional bullet point that says other one-time uses as approved by
the city council so that they have the freedom to come in and ask, and if you guys approve
sometime one-time use, that would be fine, and the second, that we segregate this out of
the general fund into a special revenue fund so that the money carries over from year to
year and doesn't get absorbed into the general fund.
Yeah, I'm totally supportive of the second one.
The first one, I'm not sure of, unless you're, if you're going to ask for something like that,
I think that the sponsor ought to know that that's what they're paying for.
So if there's a one-time thing and you need $300,000 so we can buy 18 new goals, then that
should be something that the sponsors are aware that they're paying for.
Those sponsorship fees, in addition to the program fees that the students or that each of
the eligible participants are paying, would those all go into the same fund, Ben?
Is that what you're suggesting?
That's what I would recommend, that you would have it carry over into a fund that's segregated,
separated.
I agree.
And that the flexibility, I mean, inherently, if it's a separate fund, you guys are approving
that budget anyway, and so inherently you could set money aside and all that type of thing.
I just wanted to put forward some flexibility to the community services board that they could
come back to you and they weren't precluded from at least being able to explore an option.
They might come back and say, look, we really want to replace some goals, or we need six
more goals and we don't have the resources anywhere else.
Would you be willing to entertain that to expand the program?
Exactly.
And maybe that's even an emphasis in why we're trying to get a higher level of sponsorship this
one time, this one given year, just to afford some flexibility.
That's all I'm trying to do.
Well, and I think there's safety in that, because what the sponsorship costs are and the menu
of sponsorships is already listed out in the policy.
So if there was a big ticket item to Council Member Wood's point, it would have to come back
to Council anyway for us to have it approved.
So I think there's some protection in saying it that way.
Okay, so if I'm understanding correctly, you wanted to get rid of those ones, but add in
the, I missed the fourth one, the second one.
So we want to keep provide department approved program credits or fee offsets for eligible
volunteers.
Keep that?
Yeah, because that one would allow for like volunteer coaches to be able to have potentially
their kids fee covered and that.
And, and then Ben had suggested, um, other ones as approved by city council.
How did you word it?
Other one time use considerations as approved by the city council.
And then the second one was, and does it need to be use of sponsorship funds or is it in
a different part of this policy?
Because it's all funds that come in for this.
I, I just want to create a, you know, special, just an ability to be able to give you some
flexibility.
Um, the other one is segregating it out.
And that's really just a directive to Kimberly and myself.
That doesn't need to be in the policy.
Okay.
So one question just about the first bullet point.
How are we determining who qualifies for scholarships, whether they need a partial or a full payment?
Yeah, it's really cool.
And maybe, and Kimberly asked another question here.
Um, it would be helpful to know if the council is expecting registrations to cover a hundred
percent of the cost of the program.
You know, a lot of times sponsorships will pay for like the shirts or that type of thing.
And so, um, maybe some clarity there might be beneficial.
So just quick question.
This is on the consent agenda.
Is it close enough that we can leave it there?
Or is this going to require a lot more discussion?
It sounds like it needs to come back probably in the next meeting.
Well, the problem with that, I'll just point this out, is that if we do that,
then we're not going to be able to use sponsorships for this coming season because they need to
be ordered soon for us to even be able to make the cutoff for the upcoming season that
we're taking this on.
So if we pull it and move it to another meeting, um, I, it's going to be problematic for implementing
it.
Are you saying put it on the agenda for the next meeting?
Scheduled items.
Okay, cool.
And I'm happy to make any changes in between that you tell me.
So that's, that's what I'm wondering is if maybe we give a little direction now to some
of the changes and then review those changes during the policy session on a regular scheduled
item.
Is that what I'm?
She's already making them on the fly.
I mean, if you're watching what she's doing on the first one, I'm saying, is that all
of them?
Are we done or?
That's it?
There's no other questions or changes?
Rich, did you get that, uh, the procedure, I guess?
Is that what you'd call it as far as?
Um, I did have another question though that in here, what was attached is this first initial
fee schedule.
This is what we voted on when, like in our community services board meeting.
Um, but then upon further research and common sense, this seemed to be more plausible.
Um, the, the logo on the front should cost more than the one on the back.
And so I was hoping that you guys might approve this one as well.
So we would replace the one that's in our packet with the one displayed on the screen.
Yes.
So the changes made, um, if this was to stay in the consent agenda would be removing the
bullet points as discussed and then updating the fee schedule to the one presented during work
session.
And that is all the changes that we're asking for guys.
Yes.
Okay.
So I'm just doing some math here.
If you'll go back to that one that you were just on.
If we have all of the, this one, the space used on the Jersey, what is that total going
to be for a 12 month period?
For a 12 month period.
That would be, are you talking about this one?
If every sponsorship area on the Jersey for every sport is filled.
Cause you said that's where I was going to go with that.
Is $7,500 enough?
No, no.
Ideally we would want more.
That's why I kind of feel like you benchmark this though with Saratoga Springs, the fee schedule.
I think this is pretty close with other cities.
It's, it's, it is.
The reason is, is that we started with just doing logos on the jerseys.
That was the initial thing.
We didn't have a lot of time to workshop other options and ways to make it bigger.
But that what I hoped was that we would have the opportunity.
This is why I was hoping we wouldn't, that we could update the fee schedule with just the
community services board and the manager to change it so that we could include more things
that are offered based on what makes sense.
Things like banners, things like including their links in emails and things like that.
So I, I'm doing in my mind here when, uh, Jason did the, um, presentation to us, I think we
had 6,600 applicants or participants in soccer alone.
So $7,500 is what we collect from it.
That doesn't go anywhere.
Did you say 6,600?
For spring and fall?
What was the total, Jason?
For spring and fall for soccer.
Say like $10,000, I think it was like $300,000 or something.
No, it's more than that.
For spring and fall in soccer, they were around 1,200 kids.
That's what they had.
And it's down from, it was higher than that before.
Um, if you're talking, we've, even junior jazz, we've, we've.
That had like a few thousand, right?
For junior jazz?
Yeah.
Yeah, we were, we were almost, almost 2,000 for junior jazz, but we don't, the, those jerseys
we purchased through the jazz, so we don't put anything on those.
Could I just add, add one thing?
I think that where the committee's trying to go is to at least get the jerseys going so
they can get ordered.
And then the next step would be looking at banners on the fields, maybe naming parks or
something like that where we could get more revenue generation.
But this specifically is to get the jerseys so we can print them.
I've got a lot more ideas.
We just didn't have enough time.
I also think that it's clear to council that this is an investment in the recreation program.
And I think we went into it knowing that there would be some costs.
The sponsorships are kind of an additional way for us to make it possible for more kids
and keep the costs down, but I think we all knew that it wasn't going to be covered solely
by registration fees and sponsorships.
So I think we went into it knowing that that would be the case.
Right.
And as it stands now, the city gets nothing.
So 7,500 is better than nothing, in my opinion.
I think it'll go fast, the front of the jersey.
Have we considered the prioritization?
I would say do it one season at a time.
Don't give them 12 months for every single sport.
Have it be by sport per season.
Because otherwise, I mean, it's not really serving the purpose of the sponsorship to be
able to provide scholarships for the people who are participating in it.
You're spreading it too thin for too long of a period of time over too many sports.
Part of that, too, is that they were going to be reversible jerseys so that that could
last the full year and get a little bit more mileage out of it for the families.
We could take it to just the one half of the season, basically, or the fall, like, is done.
But it would cover less then, because we have to get the jerseys anyway, the way they are.
So I guess to me, I'm also looking at, this is kind of like a pilot program, and we're
going to let them proof of concept, bring it back to us, and then we're going to make
tweaks and adjustments and refine it.
Just to, I know it seems like it's thin, but is a registration fee $60, roughly?
Does that sound right?
Yeah.
Yeah, we're right around there.
Right around $60.
If we can use some of that sponsorship money to offset fees for the jerseys, then that lowers
our prices down.
Well, that's kind of where I was going.
I mean, I don't know the intent of the council, if it's just to lower the price for everyone,
or if it's to sponsor kids that maybe wouldn't otherwise be able to play because they can't
afford it, that's 10%, it's $116, that's $60, $7,000, that you could sponsor fully.
And there's a possibility of a 50% would make that over 200 kids.
That's over 10% to 20% of the kids would get in for free or half price.
So I think it goes a little bit further than maybe anticipated because 70, 80, 90% of kids
are going to pay the full registration and that covers their costs.
So 120 kids would get in absolutely for free with this program.
Well, except for, I think the intent that Jason's talking about is the sponsorship will help
keep the overall registration for everyone down because it eats the cost of the jersey, but
then the remainder helps to cover scholarships for kids that wouldn't otherwise be able to
do it.
So I can tell, that's the intent for me, is that the registration, we keep it low.
If we're going to do a jersey that's reversible, we should be supporting that being the same
jersey because that keeps the cost down for participants to continue to use it year after
year.
If we're trying to change out sponsorships every year on that, then they're no longer an
interchangeable shirt that can be used for multiple sports, by the way, which I think
in one of the things, I'll give some credit to how Saratoga Springs is doing that part of
it, that is smart because those jerseys are used for every sport.
And that does keep the cost down for, especially people who have multiple kids that are playing
that, they just hand me down to the kids and they can play with their blue and white
jerseys.
So my intent was access fee, keep that low, have them buy the jersey that's reversible that
can be used for multiple sports.
And the way that it would work too is that it even says in the sponsorship agreement that
the jerseys are reusable.
And so the next year, there's a chance that their logo may not be on every single jersey.
And they have to be okay with that so that they can use the ones from the last season.
So do we feel like this is in a place that we can leave it on the consent agenda or is there
more discussion?
Where are we at?
Just those two changes, I think it was, striking some of that.
It's got to start somewhere.
Might as well start with this because we have to have a starting point.
But I think that there's work to be done.
So we're okay with leaving it where it's at for today.
Ben asked one question that I just think we should put some direction on.
Is the intent to, I mean, I think you've kind of addressed that, but the intent is really
to cover 100% of the cost, from my perspective, through the registration and to lower that
over time if we can.
I think we've given that instruction clear enough, right?
Okay, I just want to make sure everybody's on board.
Is there any wording in the intent or the purpose that you want me to change?
Gosh.
Sorry, Jessie, what was the question?
Sorry, is there any wording in, like, the purpose of what this policy is for that you
want me to change?
Okay.
I did have a thought.
Maybe I'm going to go back on one, something that I said, to help generate maybe some of
the bigger ticket items, perhaps field markers.
They could have a sponsorship for that.
It says their name on it.
Field one, field, you know, whatever.
Things of that nature where we're going to be replacing them every year because they get
beat to crap.
That's something that's probably smart to be able to get larger ticket items, more money
for those because everybody's going to see that when they come in to look for the fields.
So something like that makes a lot of sense to me.
And that's something we desperately need for every single sport.
So even with junior jazz, even though we're not putting it on their things, marking which
court it is with that on there would be a great way for us to do a better service to people
and also be able to get some money for it.
How about the meta field with the goalposts that have meta banners or whoever it happens
to be, right?
Right.
I mean, I think that that way they get a good bang for their buck.
And it also helps separate it.
I don't know how many of you, I'm sure most of you have been to some of the games, but
it's always kind of hard to find where your grandkids are playing or where your kids are
playing.
It's just field three and I have to travel 12 fields to figure out where field three
is.
Yeah.
I texted Steve about this last week saying that's what we should do with the fields.
So I think-
Just promise me you won't do one, three, two.
Stupid Sunrise Park in Saratoga Springs.
You always did one, three, two and nobody could find the field.
Do that.
So is that a change that we want to see here?
Do you have like a price for that?
Is there some research?
Can we add that?
They can go back and-
Yeah.
The autonomy is there.
Oh, because it's not in a rush.
Phase two.
Okay.
That one's not a hurry.
So I think we've got that.
Any other questions here?
Okay.
I'm good.
Thank you.
Appreciate that.
All right.
The 13C is a resolution approving service agreement with West Coast Code Consultants,
the third-party billing permits.
Any questions?
No?
No, I do have a question on this.
I have a couple of questions on this.
Five-year agreement.
It seems like a really long time to contract with somebody.
I'm just curious why it's five years.
And if they want five years, I want to have them give us a discount.
If it's over like a one-year or a two-year contract.
Craig, I mean, you realize that these fees, whatever they're charging, are being paid by the developers.
I mean, this is just a plan review.
This is an alternate.
This is an additional, as I understand it, building inspection team that's going to review plans.
And so whatever those costs are, they just go right through, I think.
And then I just want to identify, too, this is not an exclusive contract.
So this is just that they're going to be an approved vendor for us, that we can utilize their services for five years.
This is what their fee schedule kind of looks like.
But we have an additional contract with another company that we do.
It is not exclusive.
It doesn't mean we couldn't use somebody else.
The attempt here is basically to make sure that somebody else doesn't get to choose who they're using.
Right.
Because that is an option with the state code.
We have multiple.
And then just the volume that we have.
So mostly for us, it's because of the volume that we have, we need more than one vendor processing these for us.
Exactly.
That's what I've seen in DRC meetings is that WC3 is overwhelmed with the volume of work they're sending to them.
And what it's doing is retarding some of those applications from getting through in a timely manner.
And so this is an assistance to really to create another firm that has that expertise that can step right in and just help carry the workload.
And the costs are all whatever the costs are, and they're passed on directly to the developer.
They pass through costs.
And that was the recommendation from finance was to try to lock up prices and things for the next five years.
And the idea was like, well, we keep coming back every one to two years with this.
So rather than have to do it frequently, let's lock it down for a little bit.
The other thing it does, too, is it gives the vendor an opportunity to recognize that they're going to have a certain level of workload that they're going to need to anticipate.
And I think that it locks them into helping us make sure that they're available to review those applications.
Right?
Yeah.
Okay, 13D is an agreement.
No questions?
13E, updating section, Eagle Mountain employee policy procedures.
This was Kimberly as well.
Is there any questions or any presentation on that one?
No?
Questions?
Zach?
This was on the cell phone.
This actually, this is the COLA, basically, for statutory employees, right?
No.
Oh, that's the, this is credit card.
This was a stipend, the phone stipend.
I just have the title, so sorry.
Oh, sorry.
The phone, I don't have questions.
Okay.
It was on the, I think it was on the credit card.
So we're good on that one?
What's your credit card question?
So these are the two items that came to the council's discussion at the last meeting that we reviewed, and then this is to ratify it with the change.
So, yeah, we've talked about this, and it should have been.
Oh, okay.
My only, sorry.
I'm going through my notes, and my question was regarding the reconciliations.
It just, I think in section D5, it said review the first week, and I just wondered if maybe like having a, the seventh calendar day of the month, or something like having a specific day of the month.
So, it, it says just the first week, right?
So, for us, when we're talking about the first week, it's because there are times where our close date changes on the credit card statements.
Okay.
They have to review and have all their transactions coded within the first week of when the statement closes.
They don't have to wait that long at all.
You can, as soon as you've made a purchase, you have the ability to code and upload it.
And so, that particular item is more of an internal, like, process about the timeline that we want them to be able to do it.
But we'd rather not have it say, like, by the fifth day of the month, because sometimes that statement date changes.
It changes. Okay. Thank you.
You didn't have any questions.
All right.
13F was a resolution of Eagle Mountain City approving a contract with MHTN Architects for the City Hall and Library Feasibility Study.
Yeah.
The comment I wanted to make on this one, I just feel like that we've put a lot of effort and time and wanted a lot more input into how downtown is.
And I would like this to have two council members that are part of that decision-making body, rather than us wait until the decisions are made and then say no.
That's my opinion, if anybody else agrees with that.
And, Mayor, real quick, we do have Ryan Wallace on from MHTN to answer any questions as well.
He won't be shocked by that.
We can't hear you, Ryan, but I did warn him that that's probably what the council will want, is more involvement, which is a good thing.
And I can attest that they're really great at working with council members because...
Because we broke them in.
Well, no, council member Curtis and I worked with them on the Smith Ranch Park.
And, like, so I feel like they're great at taking the feedback and pulling us in, so.
So I think this is going to approve a contract that will allow them to start work.
I think we're going to have to have some working groups because I know that I've been, that council members have reached out more than two that want to be involved in this.
So we're going to have to go two by two or, you know, mayor and council at some point in time as this goes.
There's going to be a ton of discussion on building height and design and architectural aspects.
So I do think that Ryan and I in St. George, did it, was it?
Okay, and Craig went to dinner in St. George and had lots of discussions about different architectural things.
So we can get together two by two and work through this one, I think, without...
Why not just bring them in and let's do a meeting with all of us like they did before?
Or notice it.
And I think to start with, if Ryan's open to that, we'd almost have to because I know everybody wants to weigh in on where this goes.
So I didn't hear that.
I'm sorry.
That we should just notice a meeting.
Have a kind of a kickoff meeting with the council or I know in the proposal he talks about two meetings with the council.
I know he's probably going to want to be more involvement, but we can do it towards the beginning.
We can work with Ryan, but towards the beginning and then at certain stages where it's appropriate.
Yeah.
So if this gets approved, Ryan, maybe work with staff to pick a date or Ben, sooner rather than later, let's have a working group on this one.
Maybe we could meet an hour early.
I don't know if that fits the schedule on a Tuesday just for this and then go into our work session on a regular council day if that works.
So we'll work on that.
All right.
Is there any other questions on that one as far as the contract itself?
Okay.
Thanks for hanging with us, Ryan, for all of that.
I mean, I just want to make sure because the contract does state what we just talked about.
So who they are meeting with and how often they're meeting with, that part needs to be clear.
That it starts with the city council, there'll be a meeting in between and one at the end.
I don't think it says that right now.
So could we just say in the motion, updating the contract as discussed with the meeting, expectations with the council?
Something like that?
Yeah, something like that.
Right now it says in workshop five, which is the last step, it talks about two rounds of, no, that's the city review, sorry.
Somewhere it talks about city council up to two meetings.
But yeah, just, I think that makes sense.
What Melissa said, council member Clark.
Okay.
Moving on.
We have just a few more minutes.
And I do know I have a question here in a second, but 14A is an ordinance of Eagle Mountain City amending the youth council code 245.
Is there?
I have one question about that.
Okay.
And this is Natalie 2.45.040 duties.
And it's actually in B, limitations of the city council authority, or youth city council authority.
And we're striking number one, which says the youth city council must have a quorum in order to conduct business.
I'm curious why we're removing that.
It comes down to basically whoever shows up to the meeting will have a right to vote.
And we were concerned if, so we weren't going to limit it to only, say, five youth to being on the city council as voting members.
And the youth city council, along with advisors, recommended that whichever youth decides they want to join the city council can be a voting member.
And so we just didn't want to have to track, okay, so let's say that there's 15 of them.
Do we need seven, or do we need eight of them to have a quorum at this point?
And so the way that the code is now changed is whoever shows up is the one that wants to get a vote.
And the mayor will make a tie if there's an even number.
So that's why they modified that.
I guess I have some consternation about that.
It would be difficult for me if we decided to suspend the quorum of the city council as a decision-making body.
And yet we've got the youth council that we're trying to teach and train so they understand the way that government works.
And we're saying that there's no need for a quorum.
That's concerning to me on several levels.
I understand, Council Member Whiting, where you're coming from, that there's a big group, and are you going to have to count and keep track?
But if they're going to make decisions about where the youth council is going to do and pass motions and learn how to actually function as a council,
I find it problematic to remove the need to have a quorum present.
In theory, the mayor or the mayor and one council member could call a meeting.
Nobody else comes, and they could be making decisions that you don't want to see happen.
So the meetings have to be noticed.
But what if we did, okay, so there are a couple ways to resolve this.
One way would be, okay, a majority, a majority have to attend, or we could say simply, like a minimum number,
like there have to be at least five youth present.
I think that would feel better to me, is that there has to be at least a minimum, and that would constitute a quorum.
Okay, then let's, okay.
And I don't know what that number looks like.
It probably, that's a good question.
I mean, we've been consistent.
I mean, fortunately, we have more people that have applied this year.
That's awesome.
Which is good.
It's probably almost double the number than we normally have, which is a healthy thing.
So maybe it's easy in the quorum section to just identify we need at least, I don't know.
The quorum shall be constituted with a minimum of at least five members present, something like that.
Yeah, five.
And if they don't have five, then they can't move forward with voting on something.
Do we all feel comfortable with the number five?
Okay, I'll make the changes.
Council Member Whiting's good with that.
I'm good with that.
That was the only concern I had.
And the intent behind that, too, is, I mean, they wanted to remove seventh graders.
They wanted any youth that joined to be able to have a vote.
And so we simplified some of the language in there.
I think if you want participation, they want to feel like they have a say in it.
Otherwise, why come?
Right.
I was going to say that.
I kind of lean towards the body.
But at the same token, if you do that, you're always going to have five kids because the rest
are just feel like they're tagging along.
If you do this, everybody's involved.
It's the only real way that you can grow a program, I think.
And it makes everybody feel like they're part of it.
And they don't, they're really not making decisions that affect anyone but what they do
or whatever, so.
The next one is, no more questions on that, right?
Did you clear?
15A, a discussion about the traffic impact study of Silver Lake Parkway connection to
Saratoga Springs.
Now, I have a question on this one, only because it's been brought to my attention in other
meetings, and I don't care how this is handled, but I've heard there's going to be some people
here to discuss this.
Do you want public comment during the item or before?
It is not a public hearing.
That's why I'm asking, am I instructed to get public comment only in the public comment
period, or because this discussion is what it is, do you want the public comment to be
during the, as the discussion happens?
That's all I'm asking.
Can I just make a comment?
I think my preference would be to have the presentation, have the council discuss.
I think when we bring public comment in, if they want to comment during the opening public comment, great, but when we bring the level of emotion
in, with the presentation, it really clouds my judgment.
That's just my own preference.
I don't know if council members feel differently.
So I'd have them, if they want to make a public comment, do it at the beginning.
So keep it in the public comment section.
Keep it where it is, and then separate that from when we have the discussion on, if they want to stay and listen.
I 100% agree with that.
Because it is not a public hearing, I was just asked, are we going to allow a comment in this session?
No, I think we just follow the law and we conduct the meeting in the way that we normally would.
We've received a lot of public comment, at least I have, and I'm sure that each of you have, and that's valuable, and I value that.
But there will also be another opportunity when this comes back for adoption.
My assumption is it will be a public hearing at that point in time.
Can anybody answer that for me?
Where's David?
Marcus, this comes out as a public item when we take an action on it, right?
When the action item comes on the actual impact study, that would not be a public hearing.
No, but if we decide to adopt something to go ahead and allocate funds towards this.
Yes, when you implement, if you implement any of the plans from the study, such as improvement to intersections and things like that,
that will be a budget decision for which you will be able to formally adopt that as a council.
Yes, when you're amending a budget, for example, or adding it to the budget, there's a public hearing associated with that if it's not currently budgeted for.
And I want to be clear, I'm not saying that we shouldn't receive public hearing or public comment.
That is available every Tuesday night that we meet, and we're willing to entertain any and all of that.
But I think that to continue to make exceptions for each of these items, I just think that's a practice that we should discontinue.
Yeah, I think the only time there will be a public hearing is during a budget.
I think we need to make sure that we're intentional in letting them have an opportunity to speak about this when it comes back as an action item.
They need to have the ability to express how they feel about it, for or against it, and everybody ought to get a chance to get it out.
That way there's no question in anybody's mind that they didn't have a chance to give public comment on it.
Yeah, and I'm okay with it.
I don't really care.
I just asked the question.
But real quick, I just want to say one of the reasons why I considered it is I think if they heard the discussion of the council,
we might save ourselves 30 or 40 minutes in public comment because they might see where the council is leaning,
and that could save a lot of time.
Otherwise, we just got to listen to everybody.
So I thought, well, that could be beneficial, but I agree with just staying where we do.
I was just going to say there will be people here.
Maybe let them know if they're here to make a public comment to do it at the beginning of the meeting.
That's why I was asking.
That's what I wanted to know.
Be intentional, though, and also let them know we're not taking action today.
So if they want to give a public comment, it might be good for them to hear what the traffic study discussion and all that is,
and then they'll have an opportunity to come back and give their feedback when we take action.
That way it at least gives them a chance to understand what we're discussing.
That's just a thought.
Right.
16A is a resolution.
This is a public hearing.
It's approving the Third Amendment to the 2025-2026 physical year annual budget.
I didn't hear any questions.
I did get an answer to your question that I can tell you.
17A is also a budget, which is a truth in taxation.
I've read it every meeting we've had, but it's the same certified tax rate.
17A is the compensation increase.
It's what?
Compensation increase.
17A.
Yeah, that's the one I was talking about a minute ago with the executive officers in the fiscal year budget.
And it's no motion on that one.
Those are two separate.
16A is the fiscal annual budget.
17A is the proposed compensation increase.
Yes.
Any statutory officers with the COLA and whatnot.
And it's a public hearing only.
Sorry, I got ahead of myself.
That's why I'm on.
And then the next one is the same.
This sheet that I've read every time.
It's our certified tax rate, which actually is the 23rd.
22nd is when we'll actually get it.
But as of today, the project is 218%.
That number would be the official number if you choose to continue with the proposed revenue that's in the budget.
We did get our final valuations from Utah County that were due by the 13th.
And so we got those last, I think, Thursday.
So we made the amendments so that they were in the packet.
Those percentages and stuff would only change if the council chose to change the dollar amount of revenue that is being proposed to come from property taxes as part of the budget process.
No questions on that one?
And then 17C is the resolution adopting the fiscal year interim budget and the proposed certified tax rate.
Anything on that one that we can sort out?
Okay, and then the last one, 18A, is Ordinance of Eagle Mountain City, Utah, amending the Eagle Mountain Municipal Code 1615 on concept plans.
And I know Brandon Larson had some information on this one.
Yeah, I can talk through that a little bit.
This one, essentially what we're trying to do here is just trying to improve our development process a little bit.
So one of the things that we're trying to focus on is trying to look for, trying to make sure that right at the front of our development process that we are looking to make, looking and ensuring that we're making connections for utilities and utilities and roads.
And so the big thing here is, I guess a couple of things is just requiring some additional documents or clarifying some of the documents that we are already are requiring.
Essentially asking that the developers to give us some information to show that, you know, for instance, one of those documents is supposed to show how they're going to connect with the road system within 500 feet of their proposed development.
The other thing, too, got some feedback from a council member that maybe it might be good to be a little more judicious on how many concept plans we bring to you.
So the proposal is to generally try to take concept plans and have them end at the planning commission unless there's, I mean, there's still an ability for us to bring them on, but generally have them end at planning commission and then just take them on to council on a case-by-case basis if it's necessary.
So, but anyway, that's kind of in a nutshell what the proposal is, and then I guess the other big thing is that the concept plan would be, is typically been a, it hasn't been required, but it would be required for master developments, preliminary plats, and re-zones.
So, the one comment I have on this one, I just, thinking back in the last 12 months of when we've had them come forward to us, I think the most important thing for me is to show the full traffic circulation plan.
So, if they're, even if they're bringing phase one in, if this project has six phases, all six phases, circulation needs to be shown.
Yeah.
Because that's really what matters at that phase so that we aren't running into, basically, they're just putting in a stub here and it's going to cut off the rest of the project or adjoining properties, et cetera.
So, to me, that would be a useful purpose of the concept plan, is to be able to see what the traffic circulation plan is.
Right.
And frankly, the infrastructure, the utility infrastructure planning for me, I mean, having spent some time recently at the conference in Habert regarding water, and just spending a little more time with our public works department,
we really need to do, be more effective is probably the way I would put it in our initial review of any conceptual plan as to how we're going to service that.
And what are going to be the impacts to the system overall?
Do we have the capacity and the capability of servicing it in a way that is meaningful, or are there going to have to be some additional steps that are taken to be able to service it?
And then the demonstration that there's actually water that can support any plan that might work its way through the system.
So, I like this.
I think it's helpful.
Okay.
If there's no other questions, I did want to remind you just real quick that there will be an RDA meeting.
There's some minutes on there, and then just the agency board adopting the RDA budget for a physical year, 26-27.
Does anybody need to go over any of that?
I just wanted to ask, before we go into closed session, since the council didn't have any questions on the budget amendment,
did you want Terrence to stay and give a presentation, or are you okay with him heading out?
The budget?
Budget amendments, not a closed session.
Speak into the mic so all of us can hear what's going on.
If I wanted you to hear it, I'd say it louder.
I'm trying to work it out in my mind here.
Okay.
Relax for a second.
Does Terrence need to stay?
You don't think so?
Okay.
I don't think there's any questions on the budget amendment that I can see.
Do you have a question?
I was going to make a motion.
Okay.
Yeah.
Go ahead.
Mayor, I make a motion that the city council adjourn into a closed session for the purpose of discussing
discussion of pending or reasonably imminent litigation, the character, professional competence, or physical
or mental health of an individual, the purchase, lease, sale, or exchange of real property, a
proposed development agreement, project proposal, or financing proposal related to the development
of land owned by the state or a political subdivision and or the deployment of security personnel devices
or systems pursuant to section 52-4-2051 of the Utah code.
Second.
Okay.
We have a motion by council member Hewish and a second by council member Clark.
And we'll start the vote with council member Clark.
Yes.
Council member Wright.
Council member Whiting.
Yes.
Council member Wood.
Council member Hewish.
Yes.
Okay.
We'll go to closed session.
All right.
I think we're ready.
It is seven o'clock.
We're going to start on time.
And I know that's odd.
That's why I said that.
But before we get started,
Brett's offered to say prayer.
Our Heavenly Father,
we're grateful to bow our heads
in prayer this evening
and express our gratitude
to live in the United States of America
and in the state of Utah
and in particular
in the city of Eagle Mountain.
We give thanks for the beautiful mountains
and the rivers and streams
and just the sunshine
that we've enjoyed lately.
We express gratitude for one another.
We're grateful for the citizens
who have made time
to be here this evening
and pray that their voices
will be heard.
Bless us as decision makers
to exercise wisdom,
to listen,
to evaluate,
and to make the very best decisions
that we're capable of making
on behalf of the people
who we represent.
We pray for our staff, Father,
for our first responders,
for all of those
who serve this community faithfully
and pray that thou will bless them
with the health, strength,
and safety that they need
to do their jobs effectively.
We pray for wisdom and guidance
as we make the decisions
that we're about to embark on
and pray for our mayor
and for the council,
for our state leaders
and for our national leaders.
We express gratitude
for the opportunity
we'll have soon
to celebrate the independence
of this great nation
and do so in the name
of Jesus Christ.
Amen.
All right.
It is now 7.02 on June 16th
and we will call this meeting to order
and Council Member Clark
will lead us in the Pledge of Allegiance.
Please join me
in the Pledge of Allegiance.
I pledge allegiance
to the flag
of the United States of America
and to the republic
for which it stands,
one nation under God,
indivisible,
with liberty and justice for all.
Thank you.
All right.
Mr. Bain,
any information items?
Yes.
We have several.
First,
a shout out to those
who helped with
and participated in
Pony Express days
and the rodeo last week.
Especially appreciative
of all those great events
and all the staff
and the support of the mayor
and all of the crew
at the Pony Express events.
They did a fantastic job
and it really brought
our community together.
The food truck rally
will be held every Thursday
from 6 to 9 p.m.
starting June 4th
through August 27th.
We have a movie in the park
on June 19th
at Silver Lake Amphitheater
from 9 to 11.
The film that they're
going to be showing
is Lilo and Stitch.
There's a movie in the park
on June 26th
at Cory Ride Park
9 to 11
and that film
will be announced
to be determined.
The farmer's market
is every Saturday
at 9 a.m. to 1 p.m.
from June 6th
through October 10th
at Cory Ride Park
and the fireworks show
will be on July 4th
from 8 to 9 p.m.
And so we're excited
to honor our 250th year.
Yeah, thank you.
Lots of fun events.
Summer, we got through
Point Express days
but the summer
keeps delivering
some fun stuff.
Another fun thing,
we have a lot of employees
and they come and go
all the time
but not always in this level
and not always in the forefront
where people can yell at them
and need to know who it is.
No, I'm just kidding.
But at this time
I want to invite Brad and Zach
to introduce our new employee
that came all the way
from the West Coast
in Washington.
So, or just Zach here.
Just Zach?
Okay.
Good evening, Mayor and Council.
I am pleased to introduce
Kyle Markstrom
who has taken
our parks manager position.
We were able to steal him
all the way from Washington State.
and like it is always my pleasure
when I get to introduce someone
I always tell them
to come prepared
to tell a nice 20 minute
speech.
So, yeah.
Clearly he's not
but I really did.
He laughed.
So, but I'll turn the time over to him
and let you guys meet him.
Mayor Gray, council,
city staff, citizens,
happy to be here tonight.
Appreciate the opportunity
with Eagle Mountain City.
I'm looking forward
to serving this community
as your parks manager
and working with all of you
to further the goals
of the council
and live here with my family
and enjoy this great place.
Thank you very much.
Appreciate the opportunity.
Thank you.
Tell us a little bit
about your family.
You're bringing wife
and some kids down.
Yeah.
My wife, Kara,
my four-year-old daughter, Natalie,
will be joining me
the first part of August.
My wife's wrapping up
her commitments at work
back home
and selling our home
and they will join me here.
Natalie will start kindergarten
in the fall of 27
so we're really excited about that
and finding a great school
for her down here
and look forward
to diving into the community,
getting involved.
The community I came from
was really involved
in lots of service organizations
and on a number
of non-profit boards
and served as an elected official
in my community
and so I'm looking forward
to really diving in,
getting involved
and doing what I can
to be a good employee
for Eagle Mountain
but a good citizen
for the community as well.
Enjoys wildlife
and outdoors.
Yes.
All the fun stuff.
I love it.
The hunting opportunities
in Utah were a big draw.
I think I speak
for most of them.
They really, really
take pride in our parks
and we're excited.
I don't know.
Welcome to make any comments.
Well.
Yeah.
So thank you.
Welcome.
I was just going to say
did you bring the water
with you?
And you've got a lot
of work to do, brother.
Yeah, I didn't.
But yeah, looking forward.
Thank you.
Welcome.
Thank you all.
Yeah.
All right.
The next item 7A
is information about
some fire restriction orders
and I don't
I meant to give you
this earlier
but our fire chief
he's filling in
for Chief Fossum today
he's going to read
from the state of Utah
it's the stage one
of the drought restrictions
from this signed
by President Cox
and
or governor
yeah, he's a governor
sorry.
Don't elevate him.
A little off my
I'm off my game.
Okay, I'm on
Mayor and Council
thanks for having me here today
I should have brought my readers
I didn't know
I was going to have to read
such a small
I do
I feel pretty
so thank you
my name is Ken Aldridge
I'm battalion chief
with Unified Fire
also known as the
best Embrick could do
on short notice
so thanks for having me
I appreciate it
Fire restriction order
stage one
due to current
and forecasted weather conditions
coupled with the
extremely dry vegetation
conditions in Utah County
State Forester
in consultation
with the county commission
of the affected county
has determined
measures must be taken
to prevent the ignition
of forest and rangeland fires
therefore pursuant
to the Utah State Law
section 65A-8-212
the following acts
are prohibited
in the areas
described below
until rescinded
by the Utah State Forester
one no open fires allowed
except in the following cases
in approved fire rings
or grills
at developed campgrounds
or day use area
on public lands
that have pressurized
running water system
or in permanently
constructed fire pits
at a private residence
that have pressurized
water system available
two smoking
except within an enclosed
vehicle trailer
or building
developed recreation site
or while stopped
in an area that is paved
or free from dry vegetation
three discharging
or use of any fireworks
tracer ammunition
or other pyrotechnic devices
including exploding targets
four cutting welding
or grinding
in metal
in areas of dry vegetation
five operating
a motorcycle chainsaw
ATV
or other small
internal combustion engine
without approval
without approved
and working spark arrest
or the following
persons are exempted
from the above prohibitions
persons with a permit
or waiver issued
by the division
specifically authorizing
specific act
at a specific location
and a waiver
does not relieve
the permittee
of liability
if a fire does occur
and any on-duty firefighter
in the performance
of an official duty
area description
unincorporated areas
of Utah County
it does not affect
private lands
within incorporated towns
or city limits
any of the above acts
is a violation
of state law
punishable by six months
in jail
up to six months
and a fine of up
to a thousand dollars
these restrictions
will be enforced
by county law enforcement
that's all
and I will entertain
any questions
from the councilor
and mayor
thank you
so those fire restrictions
are in effect
and we appreciate you
helping us out
with that
so
you look great
I'm sending that picture
of your PIO
okay
now
our favorite part
of the meeting
that I know
you're all excited about
just as a note
they're back in that
corner by the door
on my left
you're right
there's a blue folder
I think
has forms for public comment
if you intend to make
public comment
go ahead and go
grab a form
fill it out
and return it over here
to our recorder
Lacey
it is now
7-11
and time has been
set aside
for public
to express their ideas
concerns and comments
please limit your comments
to three minutes
I will now open
the public comment period
as a reminder
public comment
is an opportunity
for community members
to address the city council
and each speaker
is allowed up to three minutes
if you wish to speak
during the public comment portion
please complete the comment form
located in the back
and return it to the city recorder
council members will listen
but not engage in discussion
during public comment
disruptive behavior
personal attacks
or comments
about individual city employees
are not permitted
if you have issues
questions regarding staff
or personnel
administrative staff
will meet you in the foyer
for further discussion
and Steve's our point person
if you have a personnel question
he'll meet you out back
lastly
public comment period
is for items
not associated
with a scheduled public hearing
if your comment
relates to a public hearing item
please wait until
that item is called
so the public hearing items
today that you could wait for
are 16A
which is a public hearing
about the 2025-2026
physical year annual budget
it's an amendment
17A
a public hearing
pursuant to Utah Code
1038182BI
consideration of public comment
on proposed compensation
increase for executive officers
and then 17C
resolution
of Eagle Mountain City, Utah
adopting the physical year
2026-2027
interim budget
and certified tax rate
and then 18A
an ordinance of Eagle Mountain City, Utah
amending the Eagle Mountain Municipal Code
16.15 concept plans
those four items
will be later in the meeting
and do have
time for comment
during the item
anything else
including
item
15A
which is just a discussion today
there is no action
on 15A
which is the study
of Silver Lake Parkway
connecting to Saratoga Springs
it is only a discussion
but now is the time
to speak on that item
and any other item
that you so
feel appropriate
with that
at 713
and Lacey
we do have
quite a bit
for the traffic
so I'll do
the miscellaneous
ones first
I got one
from Jody
in our inbox
earlier today
who stated
Mayor and Council
I know that most of you
know that I live
on the unpaved portion
of Lake Mountain Road
to the north
of Eagle Mountain Boulevard
I'd hope that you
would ban
any fireworks
in the subdivision
on the north
of Eagle Mountain Boulevard
and where Lake Mountain Road
intersect before now
she says
in years past
I was told by the mayor
and some council members
that the decision
had to be made
by the fire department
I'm at a loss
as to what to do
as to why there
should be a question
I would have
not only have to evacuate
not only my family
but 19 equines
and I'm not the only resident
on the three mile stretch
with similar circumstances
and then she says
well I know
and I joined in the celebration
of 250 years
don't let the possibility
become tragic
for anyone
the perfect scenario
would be a blanket
ban for the city
and at the very least
any developments
or parks
that are bordered
by potential fire fuel
so that's from Jody Hooley
and then we have
Lexi Jackson
who I believe is here
my name is Lexi Jackson
and I'm a member
of the Ecomine
Youth City Council
I'm here tonight
because the youth
of the city
needs your intervention
to protect the integrity
of chapter 2.45
of our city code
section 2.45
point 030
states that
the explicit purpose
of youth council
is to provide
an opportunity
for us to learn
to represent
representative government
through active participation
currently
that law
is being bypassed
the youth council
is being stripped
of its voice
during the pony express day
parades
decisions regarding
our participation
were made entirely
without our vote
or consent
a youth city
a youth council
hosted radio dance
was dictated to us
as a personal project
of an advisor
not a council initiative
despite being told
our presence
wasn't important
for the parade
or rodeo parking
my siblings
and I
who are
in the
Eagle Mountain
Youth Council
showed up
independently
to serve our
community anyway
more alarmingly
the adult advisor
who created
this personal project
making them
the assigned advisor
to supervise
and advise us
abandoned us
at the dance early
the event
was scheduled
until midnight
but by 11pm
they were all gone
leaving the youth
unattended
and creating
a severe liability
for Eagle Mountain
City
furthermore
we have a reason
to believe
that individuals
are operating
and making
executive decisions
as advisors
without being
formally appointed
or sworn in
violating section
2.45.020
with youth council
elections occurring
next month
we are concerned
that municipal
procedures
will not be followed
how can we learn
civic responsibility
responsibilities
from an organization
that requires
its own bylaws
and compromises
youth safety
we respectfully
request that
the city council
or city attorney
be present
for the
Eagle Mountain
Youth City Council
Mayor elections
to ensure
the compliance
of the committee
codes
Rudy Chavez
and he also
has a handout
for the council
good evening
mayor gray
city council
members
how are you
guys today
I serve
as the
American Legion
Post 111
commander
have been
for the last
three years
the American
Legion Post
has existed
since 2018
it has grown
over the last
year
in the past
we have
served
this community
for just
not veterans
but also
the community
in service
to the city
it's been
more of an
as needed
request
but what I
have submitted
to you guys
is a draft
memorandum
of understanding
requesting that
we try to
formalize
this a little
bit more
so we can
plan more
accordingly
when it
comes time
to help
support the
different city
events
some of
the things
that are
requested
in there
are
appointing
a liaison
some
small
discretionary
funds
to like
replacing
ceremonial
flags
things like
that
on an
annual
basis
and then
identifying
the different
public events
that we
would help
support
thank you
the next
group that
I have
the rest
of these
are for
the traffic
discussion
so
Melissa
Powers
and then
next one
after that
will be
James
Meyer
in the
queue
hi
my name
is
Melissa
Powers
I live
in
Evans
Ranch
I just
wanted to
thank
the city
council
and
Mayor
Gray
for all
the time
and effort
you put
into
serving
our
community
and
I
know
this
job
isn't
easy
and
I
appreciate
the
countless
hours
you
spend
trying
to
do
everything
for us
in Eagle
Mountain
I'm here
tonight
in support
of building
the Silver Lake
Parkway
connection
and moving
forward
as soon
as possible
I love
living in Eagle
Mountain
my neighborhood
and the surrounding
area are full
of families
who care
deeply
about where
they live
we care
about our
schools
our neighbors
and the future
of our community
I love
that when
people from
our area
come together
they show up
get involved
and work hard
to make it a great place to live
over the last several months
I've had countless conversations
with neighbors
friends and residents
in my area
every time this topic
comes up
the response is overwhelmingly
the same
build the road
the new high school is coming
more families are coming
growth in this area
is already happening
but for many of us
this isn't about
some future need
we already feel
the need today
we already experience
the traffic
the congestion
and the limitations
that come from having
so few connections
in and out of our area
from a resident's perspective
the connection
just makes sense
Saratoga Springs
is already moving forward
with their portion
we'd simply like to see
Eagle Mountain
move forward as well
to wrap things up
I wanted to make sure
you heard from residents
who support this project
there are a lot of us
and we are grateful
for your willingness
to listen
thank you for your service
and your time tonight
after James will be
Nancy Strickland
thank you for giving us
this opportunity
to voice
and I'm totally in agreement
I'm totally for
the Silver Lake connection
my family
we've lived here
for the last
coming up
four years
and super invested
already in
the high school
I mean
I reached out
to Melissa Clark
I don't know
if she remembers
but I teach
high school
over in West Jordan
and when I heard
that there was
a high school
that was going
to be built
literally within
half a mile
I was so excited
for that
I knew that
this was a place
where I would be able
to potentially build
my future
that my children
my three children
would be able to go
and also just the fact
that it will help
to unite
both Saratoga Springs
and Eagle Mountain
specifically
and not potentially
create a rift
you know
where it's just
a Saratoga Springs school
no this is both
Saratoga Springs
and Eagle Mountain
and so I want them
to be able to see that
and also keep our kids
off of Pony Express
I mean that road
is dangerous enough
as it is
there's no need
to have everybody
rushing to class
on that road
being on the road
you know
potentially three times
longer than they need
to be
when we could just
have a nice direct
route all the way
there
thank you
after Nancy
will be Catherine
Anderson
Nancy Strickland
here
no
Catherine Anderson
I didn't realize
I marked to speak
sorry
I'm Catherine
Anderson
I also live
in Silver Lake
I too
third
what has been said
we've lived
in Silver Lake
for almost
six years
and we have
had a child
that has graduated
from West Lake
we have
a junior
who's going
to be a senior
in the fall
and then
a son
at Vista
and a daughter
who is actually
switching schools
this fall
because our
boundary split
on our street
so I feel like
we have a good
scope
of our area
and where our kids
are going
to school
now
and it
is a feat
to get to school
I will put
a little
vouch
for the fact
that the lights
were pointed
at Vista
that was
a huge
saving grace
to us parents
that are about
to kill each other
when we drop
our kids off
trying to get
in and out
but I totally
agree with
what's been said
I feel like
Pony Express
in itself
if we can
keep our kids
off that road
giving them
a safer route
where they don't
even have to drive
if they chose
not to
and they could
walk to school
or bike to school
that would be great
I feel like
there's so many
schools in a small
concentration
and a lot of
vehicles
between those
two locations
and then all of us
getting to work
and trying to get
across Pony Express
and onto Redwood
if we had another
access route
that would take us
where we need to go
and our kids
it just makes
complete sense
I for one
am all for it
I know my children
are all for it
and would much
appreciate the fact
that if
if they
are set to go
to the new high school
that that's going to be
an accessible point
for them
thank you
I did just realize
you marked
no verbal comments
so my apologies
which
which brings me
to the next one
Corey Anderson
did you own
I can add it
to the packet
or would you like
to speak
Alex Christensen
it was great
to hear her accent
don't you all agree
I loved it
all right
hi my name is
Alex Christensen
I live in
Silver Lake
I got a chance
to meet
the city manager
Melissa
Ryan Benjamin
Jared
and Zachary
at the Silver Lake
HOA clubhouse
I want to thank you
for the first of all
the opportunity to talk
I'm here to strongly
urge the city
to move forward
with extending the road
for the Silver Lake
connection
in our neighborhood
connect directly
to the new high school
a little over a month ago
when I met with
many of these individuals
at the clubhouse
the turnout was incredible
it was easily
as many as people
that are here right now
so if you weren't there
it's like
only so many council members
are allowed to show up
before like you have to have
you know the timer
and all that stuff
so unfortunately
you guys weren't there
but you should have been
because the mayor
took out his phone
and took a photo
of everyone that
rose their hand
when they said
hey who wants
because hey
nobody wants the road
it's like
actually everybody
in the room
wanted the road
it was the number one
topic that night
and we have busy families
I don't know about you
so my alarm
was the one that went off
that sounded like
World War III
I'm in IT
so I came while I'm working
plus I cancelled
my overnight camping trip
tonight with my wife
so that I could be here
she's like
what's more important
and I said
the road
I'm not joking
okay
so this road extension
would provide safer
more direct access
for the students
walking or biking
to the new high school
my son Elias
had to cross over
Silver Lake
at the new light
went down
the sidewalk
there is no sidewalk
on the south side
of Pony Express
on his moped
and when he crossed
Pony Express
a lady ran the light
thinking that she could
make a right hand turn
he went up over the hood
and smashed
the windshield
and broke his arm
that is a crazy
dangerous road
there's absolutely
no reason for any student
to be on any type
of motorized
I mean I've even
had to look
because people
are on their motorized
just regular bikes
and those bikes
go 35 to 55 miles per hour
on their bike
you go down the sidewalk
at that speed
I'm just telling you
it's a bad idea
to have any kid
get into school
on a Mountain View corridor
Pony Express
I hope all of you
understand how important
it is to create
a just more
you know
direct route
that just bypasses
all that
let's see here
I think
oh this is what
I want to say
so
there's a clear
and distinct
impression from
everyone I've
dealt with
that they want the road
and sometimes
we get feedback
and obviously
I don't know the name
and I'm not trying
to call on anyone
but city council
people that may not
want the road
or they haven't heard
that people want
like nobody wants it
look we just want
our representatives
to understand
that the will of the people
in that entire
Silver Lake neighborhood
want the road
I think it's your job
to just step up
and give us
what we want
as an entire community
and I hope
that there's no
personal bias
or you just
do what the people want
thank you very much
Brian Morris
hi my name is
and I am also
from the Silver Lake
neighborhood
and I'm here
to voice my
support for the
connection
specifically because
while my kids
are still in
elementary school
I want this road
for when they do
go to high school
and that I can be
comfortable
and feel
that my kids
are going to be
safe as they get
to high school
they don't have
to worry about
any of the congestion
or traffic
that's already
been highlighted
before
and I think
it's important
that we have
an alternate route
out of the neighborhood
as we only have
that primarily
that one road
to get out
to Pony Express
Highway
but to have
an alternative route
in case of an emergency
would be very
important to me
so thank you
Jeff Bean
hello my name's Jeff Bean
I said this two weeks
ago so I'm not going
to repeat myself
but I do support
the road also
I'm in the Silver Lake
neighborhood
I support the road
being built
but I wanted to also
one thing I forgot
to say two weeks ago
the reason I came up
again is I do want
to make sure
another thing gets
addressed when we're
talking about roads
in Silver Lake
and that is the
crosswalk
near Brookhaven
Elementary
I think that
it's only a matter
of time
until someone
gets hurt there
seriously hurt
you know
could be lethal
it's a very dangerous
intersection
and the kids
are crossing
because it's convenient
but it's not
a safe place to cross
I think it makes
a lot of sense
as we're talking
about Silver Lake
and the roads
in Silver Lake
to prioritize
turning that into
a four-way stop
or putting a large
speed hump there
whatever it takes
to just make sure
that that's a slow road
because there's a lot
of kids crossing
the road right there
the other thing
related to roads
I just wanted to
throw an opinion
out there
and that is
and this can be
disregarded
but I know that
part of the traffic
study suggests
that the roundabout
closest to where
the new road
would be built
gets turned
into a traffic light
I think a lot of us
would enjoy keeping
that as a roundabout
if that's possible
it doesn't have to be
it's not a deal breaker
but I think a roundabout
does help keep
the neighborhood
the way that a lot
of people like it
and then finally
this is a little
bit unrelated
but as we're
on the topic
of Silver Lake
one of the
we're a little bit
of ways away
from here
and from city center
and most of my
neighbors
I don't think
even know
that we have
a library
in Eagle Mountain
it's just a little
bit of ways away
it's not always
on our way
to get here
also we do
go to the library
when we get books
sometimes we
enter delinquency
status because
we have a hard
time getting over
here to return
our books
one thing
that I think
would be very
helpful in bringing
the library to
more of us
is just having
a drop-off
location
I think Ridley's
parking lot
or somewhere near
there would be
a great place
where people
who are in
the ranches
first off
just see the fact
that we have
a library
it's almost
like a free
advertisement
but also it
gives a chance
to make sure
that hopefully
we're keeping
ourselves out
of that delinquency
status and having
a way to return
our books a little
bit easier
so that other
people can enjoy
them and that
we don't hoard
them like
sometimes unfortunately
I do
so appreciate
that
thank you for
your time
and for your
service
Ben Perez
hello mayor and
city council
members
my name is
Ben Perez
and I wanted
to just kind
of share
obviously the
same sentiment
support for
that but I
wanted to call
out a couple
things in the
traffic study
previously was
called out
the lack of
information on
that crosswalk
as I've
tried to
bring up
a lot
the traffic
study doesn't
have data
about that
intersection
that is
Silver Creek
Way and
Golden Eagle
Road
also the study
states that
there are posted
speed limits
of 25 miles
an hour
and there are
no posted
speed limits
so I want
to make sure
we consider
that
and on top
of the high
school which I
know is a hot
topic of getting
that road
connected
I think it's
really important
to consider
that while
the traffic
study is
helpful
it's great
data
it doesn't
consider things
that are out
of our control
like weather
in the squall
that we had
in January
of 2024
getting up
the hill
going west
on Pony
Express
was an
absolute
nightmare
and no one
had another
way to get
home
and so we
need some
other options
not just
getting out
and having
through
because the
study calls
out Saratoga
Springs is
bringing traffic
into the
neighborhood
as much
as it is
people trying
to get into
their
neighborhoods
and through
the city
a different
way
and a safer
instead of
congesting
the only
way into
the city
and then also
while we have
no data
on that
intersection
the PTA
and the SEC
of Brookhaven
Elementary
have spent
time out
there
counting
the amount
of accidents
that have
almost happened
near misses
and have had
recordings
of videos
as well
and we're
happy to help
provide that
information as well
we want to
keep our kids
safe
so there's
a lot of
things that we
can't undo
about Golden
Eagle Road
but I feel
like this
is a really
good opportunity
to right
some wrongs
and to find
some good
solutions
just to keep
our kids
safe
on top
of that
both for
the elementary
schools that
are there
and for the
future high
school
just to keep
our entire
neighborhood
safe
thank you
for your
time
thank you
Lindsay
Peterson
hi my name
is Lindsay
Peterson
I'm also
from the
Silver Lake
community
and I also
want to
just stand
in support
for the road
to be built
through
I like a lot
of points
that have been
mentioned
again
just unifying
the two
communities
but above
all
I feel
it's such
a safety
issue
to have
multiple
ways
to access
in and out
if there's
ever any
emergency
if you know
whether evacuations
need to happen
medical personnel
brought in
maybe both
having multiple
avenues
could possibly
save lives
in the future
so please
consider the
road
thank you
and then
the last
comment that
was received
in our office
was from
the new
principal
from the
high school
he is
actually
out of town
at a
vacation
right now
so he
requested
that we
read his
comment on
record
so he is
the new
principal
of the
high school
he's excited
to work
together
with Eagle
Mountain
Saratoga
and ultimately
he says
please do
right by
our community
by creating
the safest
access
possible
for our
students
while also
building
the road
infrastructure
necessary
to handle
the tremendous
growth
that is headed
our way
so I'll make
sure that's
part of the
packet as well
and that is
all I have
okay is
there anyone
here that did
not get the
opportunity to
speak that would
like to
last chance
come to the
mic if you
would and
turn the
mic on
please
I've never
needed a
mic but
I'm just
kidding
sorry I
could you
state your
name for the
record and
then sell out
a paper when
you're done
yes I will
yeah so
Justin Cool
I live in
Evans Ranch
neighborhood
I've been in
Evans Ranch
about six years
but I've been
this way for
about 15
16 years
I moved from
Neptune Park
here in
Saratoga so
like I
barely dipped
my toe in
Eagle Mountain
and apologies
I filled
something out
online but I
probably foobarred
that somewhere
so that's on
me but yes I
wanted to just
speak in favor of
the road as
well I believe in
not complicating
things and keeping
things simple
right the acronym
KISS
keeps simple
and you know
we can fill
out the last
one right but
like I'm not
saying like just
blindly follow
things but like
this one seems
like an obvious
one this feels
like a low
hanging piece of
fruit a layup
whatever the case
may be that
Wemby didn't
do in the
finals and
it's just like
we it just
seems really
obvious that
this one would
work right in
things of that
nature from a
safety standpoint
anytime you can
have more access
and I know
we're talking
about you know
safety and
some of that
nature too
and I don't
pretend to know
how this would
have altered
things I mean
it's not like
there wasn't
a fire like
a couple feet
from everybody's
house at
Brookhaven and
stuff like that
again another
access point
my daughter
Boston goes
to Brookhaven
so I'd love
to also chime
in on the
you know the
crosswalk and
everything like
that at
Brookhaven
she's a spit
fire you know
I'd love to
pretend like she
follows all the
rules that I
set for her but
sometimes kids
dart out and
things happen
like that right
and anything we
can do to slow
down and keep
it safe so I'd
be in favor of
that as well
I'm gonna
contradict and
I apologize
sir please
take out the
rotary or
roundabout
whatever they're
called out here
I'm from Boston
we trying to get
rid of all the
rotaries so like
I'm all for
getting rid of
that I know
I'm disagreeing
and I apologize
but maybe don't
keep that one
thank you and I'll
fill out that
form appreciate
your time
all right last
chance for a dad
joke haven't heard
one for a long
time
oh no
fill out a paper
if you would
and turn your
mic on it's
there you go
you goaded me
and I had to
do it so
my name is
Colby Curtis
I live in
Silver Lake
and I'm just
gonna echo as
well I think
one of the
things that's
really important
to me from
my perspective
is that we
had a lot of
trouble with
working with
Saratoga Springs
to get the
light in at
Woodhaven and
now that they're
wanting something
I just think
it's an
opportunity for
us to be
to collaborate
a little bit
better than I
felt like they
did with us
sometimes and so
you know that on
top of everything
else I do think
that it will help
safety and other
things and yeah
that's all I do
say I talked too
much for far too
long here so
but oh the dad
joke so where do
you find a dog
without legs right
where you left
him thank you
bring bring
your form if
you want or
you're not done
filling it out
go ahead okay
hi council
mayor I'm
Steve Fisher
also in
Silver Lake
I am fully
in support of
the road but
also I did
want to bring
up something
that Ben
was it he
had mentioned
and I actually
thought it would
be important for
you guys to
hear as well
so I live on
Silver Creek
Way which is a
road that Melissa
I mentioned
already has
speeding issues
but going on
to Golden Eagle
it is a disaster
at one point
at the three-way
crosswalk
where the state
trust land is
I saw two
sheriffs and
I talked to them
and I said
hey I am
extremely confused
there's a 25
up there
there's a 30
at the bottom
of the road
what's the speed
limit here
and he said
the county
has it at
35 miles an
hour between
the schools
and he says
I've been trying
for months
to get them
to put a
speed limit
sign here
and they
said that the
county hasn't
done anything
so it is
clearly a known
issue with the
sheriffs and
they know that
that road is
dangerous and
I fully agree
that at some
point that is
going to become
an issue and
speeding in that
in Silver Lake
in general is an
absolute problem
problem and
it's not just
Golden Eagle
it's throughout
the community
and living on
a connector
it's been a
real problem
so road
yes
enforcing speed
limits
yes
thank you
you're welcome
to come up
state your name
for the record
and then fill
out a sheet
sorry I'm late
because I had
to take my
kid to a
sporting event
but I was
listening on
my phone
so I could
make sure I
don't repeat
anything
my name is
Scott Griffith
I've already
spoken with
the mayor
and the council
but this time
instead of
talking about
the connector
road
which I'm
totally
in support
of
I wanted
to talk
about
just
Golden Eagle
Boulevard
and
Silver Creek
Way
again
my wife
has videos
of kids
almost getting
hit
she sat
there and
just pulled
out her
cell phone
and I
think we
got four
in one
day of
kids running
out in
front of
cars
not being
able to
see
because
the parents
park
alongside
that road
in front
of the
church
and
it's
just
every day
it's so
scary
like I
said
I wish
we still
had school
in session
so you
guys could
go in
and watch
the traffic
but
yeah
there's a
couple
things wrong
with that
road
I believe
the speed
limit says
wherever the
sign is
I don't
know
but I've
driven up
and down
it before
and I
see 35
it's way
too fast
like the
fact that
you can
drive just
as fast
in that
road
as you
can
in front
of
the
high
school
road
where
main
traffic
is
flowing
like
shocking
to me
and then
the fact
that there's
no stop
sign or
speed bump
or anything
to stop
cars
because we
all know
if the
speed limit
says 35
people are
going 45
and for
that to
happen
when kids
are crossing
the street
it's like
literally
if you guys
sit out
there
it's cars
streaking
or slamming
on their
brakes
to miss
kids
and I've
submitted
multiple
complaints
or not
but multiple
suggestions
to the city
and every time
the response
has been
the traffic
study
says that
we don't
need one
yet
and I
probably
imagine
the traffic
study
that they're
referring to
was probably
done whenever
that road
was made
in like
when there
was a
billion less
houses
in Eagle
Mountain
so the fact
that we
can't
put up
a stop
sign
when the
growth
of that
area
has increased
by 2200
homes
is concerning
to me
and I
just wish
that we
could do
something
about that
immediately
like if I
could go
up and put
a stop
sign in
there tomorrow
a four-way
stop I
would love
to but
I'm not
allowed
so anyway
I appreciate
it and I
really appreciate
your guys'
time and
attention
thank you
all right
if you
just fill out
a form
and return
it
then
did I
miss
anybody
that
didn't
get a
chance
to speak
I
believe
that's
everybody
there
was a lot
of online
comment as
well
that we'll
get to
everybody
so with
that at
we'll close
the public
comment period
and come
back to the
council and
just as a
reminder I
know that
later Mr.
Salazar is
going to give
us a
presentation
I just
don't want to
forget about
the 35 mile
I think it's
because of the
type of road
that it is
right
so we'll
address the
speed limit
through the
study right
so anybody
that wants
to hear
that
we'll come
back to
the council
and start
on this
side
councilmember
hush
I really
appreciate
those who
have come
and I've
had an
opportunity to
go with
with Ben
Perez and walk
through that
area and I
just thought
how did we
end up with
two
elementaries
and now a
high school
all within
a quarter
mile of
each other
what was the
school district
thinking
it's it's
pretty crazy
through that
area
I just
wanted to
just share
a quote
from Benjamin
Franklin
on the
freedom of
speech
he said
the freedom
of speech
is a
principal
pillar
of free
government
when this
support is
taken away
the constitution
of a free
society
is dissolved
and tyranny
is erected
on its
ruins
and I
it's just
been in
my mind
it seems
like there's
no shortage
of people
online
canceling
other people
and I'm
just grateful
for the
freedoms that
we have
I'm grateful
that I've
sat there
and I've
addressed the
city council
and come
and express
frustrations
that I've
had
and it
really is
meaningful
to have
you here
to hear
your concerns
and desires
and for
safety in your
neighborhoods
it really is
meaningful
and so
I just
wanted to
express my
gratitude
for the
freedom of
speech
that we
have
and enjoy
and that's
all
thank you
I live in
Silver Lake
also
I'm glad to
hear all of
you
I'm grateful
that you
came and
said everything
that you
said
I do
want to
address one
thing
we've
gotten a lot
of emails
about a
certain
council member
not agreeing
to put the
road through
there isn't
anybody up
here
that has
said that
so I
just
want to
dispel
that
whoever's
saying
that's
not
true
the reality
of it is
is that
we're trying
to make
decisions
based on
all of
the things
that you
just
talked
about
how do
we make
it safe
we have
two
elementary
schools
that are
there
we'll
infuse
young
drivers
that are
inexperienced
going through
that
situation
a road
that's
probably
too fast
for the
number
of kids
that are
walking
on that
road
I do
want to
tell you
one thing
that I
think
you'll
like
we
funded
speed
tables
and we
will be
putting
those
in the
school
zones
where
they're
going
to
exist
exactly
but for
sure
Brookhaven
and Silver
Lake
are on
that
list
so
just
you
know
that's
already
going
to
happen
we're
working
through
that
right
now
and
we
feel
the
same
way
safe
routes
to
school
safety
for
the
kids
has
been
at
the
forefront
of
these
discussions
with
Silver
kids
to
walk
so
they
weren't
on
Porter's
Crossing
so
I
want
you
to
know
that
like
the
decisions
that
are
being
made
with
regards
to
this
are
safety
first
we're
starting
with
that
premise
then
we're
moving
on
to
traffic
flow
connectivity
etc
that
has
to be
the
way
that
we
approach
this
we're
going
to go
through
this
study
when
David
comes
up
we're
going
to
talk
about
this
and
we're
going
to
make
the
best
possible
decision
with
the
data
that's
available
to
us
address
as many
of the
things
as we
can
that
have
been
brought
up
one
thing
I
want
you
to
be
aware
of
maybe
hasn't
been
brought
to
your
attention
there's
a
major
road
that
we
have
been
working
on
for
quite
some
time
called
the
lake
mountain
corridor
it's
going
to
come
over
the
top
of
mountain
one
of
the
concerns
is
in
connecting
the
way
that
you're
suggesting
that
might
jeopardize
that
road
from
being
able
to
be
built
in
the
way
that
we
want
it
to
be
built
so
that
it
benefits
50,000
people
on
the
other
side
of
the
mountain
so
again
there
are
other
aspects
to
this
that
we
are
trying
to
consider
all
of
those
things
to
make
sure
we're
giving
safe
routes
passage
for
everybody
neighborhoods
that
they're
in
give
better
traffic
flow
so
we're
not
overburdening
Pony
Express
that
we're
utilizing
the size
of roads
the ways
that
they've
been
intended
to
so
I
just
want
you
to
know
this
isn't
flippant
we're
not
in a
hurry
to
make
the
decision
because
it
needs
to
be
the
right
decision
it
affects
my
children
they
go
to
West
Lake
if
they
decide
to
put
our
kids
into
the
new
high
school
we'll
go
to
the
new
high
school
as
well
right
now
that's
kind
don't
know
how
that
looks
so
I
want
to
be
clear
and
transparent
with
you
whatever
has
been
said
has
not
come
from
the
five
of
us
up
here
we
care
about
the
outcome
of
this
it
affects
me
specifically
people
I
care
about
not
just
my
own
kids
I
care
about
the
people
who
live
in
my
community
that's
why
I
ran
for
city
council
was
to
stop
some
of
the
bad
decisions
that
were
being
made
I
know
that
when
Kobe
ran
he
did
the
same
thing
and
I
know
that
he
can
tell
you
and
attest
that
matters
to
each
of
the
people
that
are
up
here
that
safety
is
the
most
important
thing
for
us
so
I
just
wanted
to
make
sure
I
said
that
you
heard
it
from
me
I
am
available
by
telephone
to
call
anytime
if
you
want
to
know
if
I
said
something
you
should
know
me
well
enough
by
now
I
will
tell
you
what
I
think
am
not
going
to
try
sugarcoat
anything
I'll
tell you
exactly
and
I'll
give
you
data
driven
decisions
of
why
I
want
to
make
the
decision
that
I'm
making
thank
you
for
being
here
I
appreciate
you
being
here
we're
better
when
you
are
speaking
out
thank
you
for
bringing
up
mile
an
hour
zone
we're
going
to
fix
that
and
having
inappropriate
signage
we're
going to
fix
that
too
we
can
make
telephone
calls
to
fix
that
problem
we
here
at
this
meeting
and
I
just
wanted
to
go
back
in
time
a
little
bit
let's
go
back
years
ago
4th
of
July
John
Adams
on
that
day
passed
away
there
were
a
couple
statements
he
made
that
day
I
want
to
comment
on
one
he
said
independence
forever
it's
one
of
his
statements
now
he
was
struggling
to
make
any
statements
on
that
day
of
his
death
but
that's
Jefferson
survives
and
the
reason
why
that
one
is
interesting
little
did
John
Adams
know
at
that
time
Thomas
Jefferson
had
already
passed
away
the
night
before
July
3rd
Thomas
Jefferson
was
already
on
his
death
bed
he
was
drifting
in
and
out
of
consciousness
when
he
would
come
back
into
consciousness
he
would
ask
the
people
around
him
is it
the
fourth
of
July
yet
he
was
willing
his
body
to
make
it
to
one
more
day
and
he
did
made
it
to
one
more
day
there
so
they
both
died
on
the
same
day
4th
of
July
years
exactly
after
the
signing
of
the
Declaration
of
Independence
when
the
founding
fathers
taught
us
that
there
was
a
providential
hand
that
set
up
this
country
that
was
one
more
significant
symbol
from
our
providential
divine
source
to
let
us
know
that
he
did
and
I'm
grateful
for
that
my
invitation
to
you
what
are
you
doing
as
a
individual
and
as
a
family
to
honor
this
4th
of
July
a
little
differently
than
you
have
done
prior
4th
of
July
ask
yourself
that
question
for
me
my
family
we've
been
studying
the
lives
of
the
signers
of
the
Declaration
of
Independence
them
we
have
other
things
planned
as
well
but
that's
one
thing
that
we
have
been
doing
I
would
invite
you
all
to
elevate
your
4th
of
July
celebrations
this
year
and
to
remember
not
only
the
signers
and
those
who
were
there
that
created
the
Declaration
of
Independence
and
signed
it
and
put
their
lives
at
risk
but
also
remember
who
the
signers
also
acknowledged
as
helping
set up
this
country
thank
it's
always
hard
to
follow
Craig
sometimes
I
want
to
be
adopted
into
the
Whiting
household
let me
just
say
it
that
way
Craig
is
my
neighbor
and
friend
I
value
him
and
his
perspective
a great
deal
as I
do
each
of
my
colleagues
here
and
I
invite
you
to
come
participate
with
July
enjoy
the
fireworks
that
are
going
to
happen
at
Cory
ride
park
that's
you
to
come
and
participate
in
that
listen
to
the
music
and
just
really
get
a
good
sense
and
it's
an
awesome
fireworks
show
and
it
runs
a lot
longer
than
it
does
in
almost
anywhere
else
so
come
and
enjoy
that
we
were
trying
to
reverse
the
traffic
flow
so
the
people
would
stay
here
and
not
be
looking
to
leave
all
the
time
that
was
at least
one
of our
objectives
in
funding
what
makes
governmental
interactions
I think
function
when we
agree
to
disagree
and
we're
not
disagreeable
with
one
another
so
I
love
that
there
was
some
disagreement
about
whether
roundabout
should
stay
very
civil
and
so
I
want
to
read
a
quote
and
this
is
a
quote
from
Diane
Sucra
and
you
won't
know
her
but
this
comes
from
her
book
Save
Your
City
at
its
heart
civility
is
the
disposition
of
those
who
understand
that
we
live
together
to
flourish
together
that
the
well-being
of
our
neighbor
is
bound
to
our
own
and
that
we
have
a
duty
to
one
another
and
to
the
common
good
my
commitment
promise
to
you
is
that
each
person
seated
here
on
this
dais
evening
shares
this
vision
of
what
we
have
a
responsibility
to
that
we
are
bound
to
you
oh
I
just
want
to
say
ditto
before
I
jump
into
my
thoughts
there's
going
to
be
a
declaration
of
independence
reading
at
Cory
Ride
on
July
also
happens
bingo
squares
on
the
official
Eagle
Mountain
bingo
card
so
make
sure
you
do
that
I'm
really
grateful
for
everyone's
thoughts
about
our
duty
to
serve
and
our
duty
to
each
other
I'm
also
really
grateful
for
the
acknowledgement
of
from
where
our
rights
come
but
more
importantly
from
whom
our
rights
come
and
I
I grew
up
in
Minnesota
and
some
of
you
guys
know
that
Laura
Ingalls
Wilder
is
from
Minnesota
and
I
loved
watching
Little
House
on
the
Prairie
when
often
thought
about
what
it
must
feel
like
years
from
now
when
people
look
back
and
say
who
decided
that
this
park
would
go
here
or
why
is
this
road
here
or
why
is
you
know
any
number
of
decisions
that
we
made
and
I
am
reminded
of
the
story
from
Little
House
on
the
Prairie
when
they
wanted
to
make
a
bell
for
their
school
and
their
church
building
and
they
didn't
have
the
money
kids
got
together
and
brought
their
little
tin
soldiers
and
everything
a
guy
in
their
community
named
Tinker
melted
all those
toys
together
and
all
their
thoughts
and
bringing
it
together
so
that
we
could
together
create
the
big
bell
the
history
future
of
Eagle
Mountain
and
I'm
grateful
for
all
the
little
pieces
and
all
the
little
thoughts
and
contributions
that
every
single
one
of
you
make
silently
every
single
day
taking
care
of
your
neighbors
mowing
lawns
for
a
senior
neighbor
you
know
bringing
a meal
in
for
somebody
that's
struggling
and
we
couldn't
be
who
we
are
without
your
contributions
and
much
like
councilmember
whiting
spoke
about
the
founding
fathers
of
our
country
you
guys
are
the
founders
of
this
city
and
you're
part
years
from
now
we
will
be
remembered
for
who
we
are
today
so
thank
you
all
for
that
you
do
and
thank
you
for
attending
and
sharing
your
thoughts
and
keeping
us
on
our
toes
okay
yeah
I'll
just
echo
that
too
thanks
for
being
here
I
appreciate
it
I
just
wanted
to
add
my
appreciation
to
all
the
people
who
helped
with
the
past
couple
of
weeks
Pony
Express
days
and
especially
behind
the
scenes
or
unseen
people
the
Pony
Express
board
that
most
of
them
don't
get
the
credit
or
get
seen
some
of
our
staff
I
know
there's
been
a ton
of
work
by
our
new
community
service
board
and
of
course
Steve
who
spends
a ton
of
time
doing
his
other
responsibilities
plus
that
but
then
all
the
rest
of
the
staff
that
just
comes
to
work
every
day
and
goes
home
and
we
don't
always
know
what
they
do
so
thank
you
for
what
you
do
and
then
our
non-profits
as well
you know
I hear
from Rudy
today
at the
Legion
they're
there
selling
waters
and candy
and whatever
else
they have
and
some
of
our
other
groups
as well
that
just
really
make
our
community
what
they
are
you
know
he
gave
us
a
handout
of
some
the
events
I
do
like
holy
cow
a
big
shout
out
and
thanks
to
those
time
but
who
lift
where
they
stand
and
who
are
out
there
doing
the
work
that
we
don't
always
see
and
sometimes
goes
unnoticed
but
they
just
keep
making
our
community
a
better
place
someone
asked
me
this
week
about
our
size
I
actually
did
an
interview
a
news
interview
and
they
were
talking
about
man
how
do
keep
that
small
town
feel
in
a
town
of
80,000
people
and
I
said
you
know
it's
kind
of
amazing
because
there's
other
communities
around
us
that
have
less
than
that
you
don't
feel
that
same
thing
I
said
it's
because
we
still
wave
at
each
other
when
we
pass
on
the
streets
and
we
stop
in
the
middle
of
the
road
and
talk
to
each
other
at
the
store
I
think
that
goes
to
the
character
of
each
one
of
us
who
chooses
to
keep
this
community
what
it
is
and
that's
a
choice
we
make
and
a
hope
of
mine
that
we
continue
to
remain
that
hometown
we
all
expect
it
to
be
so
thanks
for
being
here
thanks
for
and
come
to
the
4th
of
July
all
the
things
coming
up
and
I
going
to
apologize
I
feel
like
off
my
game
today
losing
track
of
where
we're
at
and
fumbling
around
a little
bit
I
thought
had
this
mayor
thing
down
after
only
days
not
that
I'm
counting
but
it's
we're
on
number
yeah
okay
good
so
let's
go
on
I
like
that
hint
so
we'll
keep
going
with
that
we'll
close
the
public
comment
period
and
or
our
council
period
and
go
to
the
earlier
and
Melissa
has
a
motion
ready
prepare
yourself
for
the
longest
motion
ever
made
mayor
I
move
that
the
city
council
approve
the
consent
agenda
with
changing
item
13b
section
use
of
sponsorship
funds
striking
bullets
bullet
points
through
beginning
with
purchase
and
maintain
ending
with
cover
administrative
adding
an
bullet
point
other
one-time
use
of
funds
approved
by
the
city
council
updating
the
appendix
a
fee
schedule
to
the
updated
fee
schedule
as
presented
in
work
session
also
item
13f
directing
staff
to
update
the
scope
of
work
to
include
a
kickoff
meeting
noticed
for
the
full
city
council
and
an
emphasis
placed
on
including
city
council
members
throughout
the
process
also
item
14a
referencing
2.45.040
section B
limitations
of the
youth city
council
authority
making
updates
to the
numbering
of items
one through
four
and
item
one
and I'm
going to
read
exactly
the way
it should
read
number
one
the youth
council
must have
a quorum
in order
to conduct
business
a quorum
is one
more than
half of
the youth
city council
voting
members
or at
least
five voting
members
whichever is
less
second
now I know
that was a
big motion
is it
any questions
any
I fully
expected the
30 second
warning to
come up
in the
middle of
it
okay we're
going to
start the
vote with
council member
wood
yes
council member
whiting
yes
council member
right
yes
council member
clark
yes
and that
passes
and I
didn't state
the motion
in second
council member
clark and
right
just for
the record
now we
are to
the
favorite
part
15 a
a traffic
impact
study of
silver lake
parkway
connecting to
saratoga
springs
and our
traffic
engineer
david
salazar
is here
to present
some
findings
just as a
reminder
there's no
action taken
but we will
have some
time for
questions and
comments
mayor I'm
just wondering
what does it
feel like to
be the
traffic
engineer
in one of
the busiest
cities in
the state
that's growing
at the pace
that we
are
only one
guy knows
it's fun
it presents
challenges and
I like
challenges so
I'm glad to
be here this
evening mayor
council members
I too live in
silver lake
elementary so
this particular
study was very
interesting for
myself my
daughter goes
to just
graduated from
silver lake
elementary so
I'm very
excited to be
here tonight
to present
hails
engineering
they're going
to go over
the study
the parameters
of the study
the results
findings and
then I'll
conclude with
recommendations
I was also
going to respond
to a couple
comments from
public comments
that were also
in the study
but are not
necessarily in
the presentation
but I think
are worthwhile
mentioning
so with that
I'll turn over
to hails
engineering
so I'm
Jordy Barrett
with hails
engineering
I'm a licensed
professional engineer
I'm one of the
project managers
there and I've
worked a little
bit on this
study and
yeah
Dallin will
take the lead
on this
presentation
he's very
knowledgeable
and more
charismatic
than me
so
hello
I'm Dallin
Barrowman
I'm a
transportation
planner
at hails
engineering
and I'll
be going
over some
of our
findings
observations
and recommendations
related to
the silver
lake
transportation
study
so this
covers
these two
alternative
connections
silver lake
parkway
connection
shown in red
in the map
you can see
on the screen
there
and then
B
Porter's
Crossing
shown in green
this map
outlines different
roadway connections
as seen in the
future roadway
network
you can see
there in the
blue line
lake mountain
corridor
which will be
kind of a new
major regional
connection
all connections
here
pertain to
increased grid
connectivity
and redundancy
and safety
improvements
as mentioned
earlier
Pony Express
Parkway
experiences
a lot
of congestion
so having
these
connections
improves
those
redundancy
measures
additionally
with these
connections
there's
improved
safety
with having
access for
first responders
and EMS
services
in the case
of related
accidents
and wildfires
and such
as is
for our
analysis
we looked
at three
different years
and 2050
in each
of these
years
we looked
at the
background
conditions
these are
with no
connections
built
and in
we also
looked at
the
Civil Lake
Parkway
connection
and in
we looked
at not
only
the
Civil Lake
Parkway
but also
Porter's
Crossing
and
combined
AB
both
connections
scenarios
one
aspect
of our
analysis
was looking
at
cut-through
traffic
in 2035
before the
Lake Mountain
corridor
approximately
half of
all traffic
through
Silver Lake
Parkway
connection
is estimated
to be
from these
cut-through
traffic
trips
and this
is primarily
to avoid
congestion
on Mountain
View
Corridor
and Pony
Express
Parkway
as a
collector
road
it is
to be
expected
servicing
all those
trips
that are
trying to
make
efficient
travel
decisions
but by
with
Lake Mountain
Corridor
we expect
that cut-through
percentage
to drop
significantly
this is
larger
because
it becomes
less desirable
of an option
with the
Lake Mountain
Corridor
and people
can cut
through
other means
now
the bulk
of our
analysis
was looking
at
level
of
service
this is
an A
through F
scale
kind of
outlining
different types
of congestion
levels
for our
purposes
intersections
with A
through D
level of
service
were deemed
acceptable
and then
E and F
conditions
were failures
and we
recommended
mitigations
to go
along
with those
here
you can see
the table
ES1
figure
or table
this is
in the
draft report
outlining
the different
years
and their
associated
scenarios
you can see
there on
the left
side
the eight
intersections
that we
studied
as well
as
AM
and PM
results
from our
modeling
as you
can see
we have
a few
E and F
results
related to
these
intersections
highlighted
there
in
we've
looked at
Woodhaven
Boulevard
and Point
Access
Parkway
and found
it would
operate
at level
service
E
we
recommend
the
northbound
dual
right
turn
lanes
that is
currently
being
conceptualized
by the
city
we just
show
that it
meets
demand
in the
current
background
looking
forward
to the
background
scenario
in the
evening
peak
period
we see
two
intersections
that
reach
failure
conditions
these
are
Porter's
Crossing
Parkway
and
Woodhaven
Boulevard
it's
understood
that
Point
Express
Parkway
is
in excess
of
capacity
there's
about
35,000
trips
per day
on this
roadway
and so
we
recommend
by
widening
to seven
lanes
through
the study
area
from
Mid Valley
Road
to
Mountain
View
Corridor
with
its
improvement
we
expect
that
it
would
improve
from
level
service
ENF
to
level
service
C
in
addition
to
level
of
service
standards
we
also
looked
at
significant
queuing
in
the
Silver Lake
Parkway
we
encountered
one
such
instance
Silver Lake
Parkway
and
Golden Eagle
Road
we
expected
to be
having
the
significant
queue
in the
southbound
direction
of
about
feet
it is
currently
a roundabout
but we
recommend
improving
it to
a
signalized
intersection
with
added
left
turn
lanes
on
each
approach
with
this
improvement
it
would
improve
from
feet
to
and
accept
queue
length
not only
would it
improve
the queue
length
anticipated
at the
intersection
but also
provide
improved
pedestrian
connectivity
currently
the
local elementary
school
has
Golden
Meadow
crossing
as its
designated
crossing
but with
the Golden
Eagle
Road
and Silver Lake
possible
signal
there's
more
protected
and
designated
crossing
allows
for greater
caution
for roadway
users
as well
an additional
improvement
that we
saw
from our
general
traffic
observations
is that
Silver Lake
Parkway
and
Woodhaven
Boulevard
this
intersection
didn't
have
any
failures
in it
low
service
or
excessive
queuing
but we
noticed
a large
amount
of traffic
in the
north
and south
bound
directions
and so
in order
to match
this
traffic
pattern
we
recommend
aligning
it into
a T
intersection
with
signalization
this is
an optional
improvement
but we
think
it could
be a
good
way
to
improve
pedestrian
access
and
kind
of match
the intention
of the
intersection
along
with this
improvement
we would
need to
have
Campbell
circle
be made
into
emergency
exit
only
and to
rename
the southern
leg to
Woodhaven
Boulevard
for that
consistency
at the
intersection
other
recommendations
we cover
in the
report
is
Woodhaven
Boulevard
there's a
cluttered
mailbox
on the
north end
of the
roadway
which can
kind of
create
these
moments
congestion
and
blockage
this
related
to
mail
carriers
and
residents
picking
up
and
dropping
off
mail
and so
we
recommend
moving
it
to
a
side
street
to
eliminate
this
kind
of
spontaneous
blockage
additionally
by
Silver Lake
Elementary
School
we
recommend
a
traffic
calming
measure
of
white
striping
along
Golden Eagle
Road
and
Silver Lake
Parkway
this
would
help
facilitate
street
parking
and
allow
for
more
caution
during
pick up
and drop
off
periods
with
these
designated
parking
areas
so
from
our
analysis
we
have
culminated
this
table
with
new
recommendations
and
costs
you
see
it
shows
the
improvement
phasing
and
the
associated
cost
this
ranges
from
the
woodhaven
boulevard
relocation
of
mailboxes
to
the
point
express
parkway
on
the
higher
end
and
this
is in
the
report
now
I'll turn
over to
C-Saf
thank you
so
from this
study
we can
get into
specifics
when you
guys have
questions
as well
we
recommend
making
the
connection
to
Silver Lake
continuing
that road
with
that
we
recommend
the
signalized
intersection
at
Golden Eagle
and
Silver Lake
Parkway
improving
that intersection
pulling all the safe walking routes to that intersection
we would also recommend realigning Woodhaven at this intersection
and having Woodhaven continue on south again to help with pedestrian access
crossing and roadway conflicts
and then we'd also recommend moving the mailboxes there's a there's some good city right
of way on some of the adjacent side streets we could relocate that to
the cost here you know the the Pony Express widening that that is something part of their study they looked at as well it would not necessarily be needed in the immediate improvements you know for the immediate improvements you know for the immediate improvements we'd be looking at the
the silver lake parkway in the woodhaven and silver lake parkway intersection as well so
kind of the bottom two plus the the relocation of the mailboxes with this study we collected traffic volume but one of the things we didn't do at the time was getting speed data vehicle types things of that nature so I've sent emails to you guys as well one of the things we'd like to do for the city is do a citywide speed study
we have so far identified 20 locations all the elementary schools are on there as well as well as some very high populated intersections and we would like to conduct a speed study in that area so we can have more speed speed vehicle types and so on we have volumes because one of the comments was silver creek way and with the volume we have right now it did not warrant an all-around stop sign now it's the
we know speed is an issue on golden eagle no one's denying that but stop signs are not traffic calming measures using a stop sign to manage speed is a dangerous practice and I do not recommend it people will not follow stop signs it can create a false insecurity for pedestrians crossing you get people speeding up and slowing down even more than if it hadn't been there now there were other ways we can mitigate speed which is why we're proposing the speed study to look at especially that intersection as well as golden eagle and
other places other places throughout the city but that was not part of this study that's something we would like to propose kind of next steps but I did want to address the speed sign the stop signs excuse me in that area first
so and then the last thing I was going to mention was um uh lake mountain corridor even with this connection you know this is a local road when thankfully lake mountain corridor is now a udot facility
so when they come in there you know udot is kind of you know it's the state and they will adjust roads and move things as needed to accommodate that arterial
because they know it's critical so making this connection would not inhibit lake mountain corridor coming through at a later date this would serve the immediate needs of the city with hopefully lake mountain corridor coming sooner
so that's all i have for now but i'm happy to answer questions as well as technical questions would you mind pulling up the drawings that are on this report that shows the
woodhaven pony express silver lake pony express enhancements uh that you're they're going to be coming so that the residents can at least see that the double right lane and the uh continuous right
i don't remember where i saw that in 170 pages but it's in there you mean uh you mean for the um the turn lanes
correct yep just so that they can see that there's some immediate things that are coming as well as some
things in the future i think it's important for them to be able to see that there is some progress that's
happening but it's not all 10 15 years down the road so this summer we have two projects that are funded
designed and bids were due today so we're planning to do these projects this summer if you look in the map
hopefully everybody can see it north is to the left bony express runs in this direction this is silver
lake parkway we are widening this road on the south leg adding a designated right turn lane a separate
through lane and a left lane so we no longer have the through lanes backing up the rights for the am peak
when everyone's trying to get out of the city and go to work that's silver lake parkway now when we go to
woodhaven here's woodhaven which is my neighborhood as well we're adding the second
right hand turn so at the intersection this one's gonna be a little bit different because we have so
many rights here we're adding a dedicated right turn lane a through and a right and a left and the reason
why this one has a through and a right is because across the streets saratoga springs is doing a
commercial development called the rider station and that's going to be going in later this fall i'm not
sure when it's going to be occupied but they're working on the intersection this fall and we don't
see the conflict with the through movement and the right am peak movements because those commercial
businesses will be closed in the morning this way we can utilize two lanes to head right leaving the
city but during the day you know you have a lot less am peak so the the throughs and the rights don't
do you have a conflict like you do over on silver lake where people are going through to mount saratoga
to 73
thank you one other thing i just wanted to i mean you said this but i just want to highlight
that the the speed table discussion was not part of this study it's something that's going to be
coming after the fact that will help with deterring speeding and even how that lower section is going to be
contemplated so i just want to make sure that everybody hears us say we are doing something
there are a number of things that are going to be immediate things and some of these things are
going to be funding to get the funding to be able to do those things so i just want to make sure we
say that yep and these speed studies are pretty quick we're hoping to get something executed started
in the next month and we can hopefully come back to you guys in the next month or so
as far as the approval process we're updating the transportation master plan
with some section updates as well as running some modeling for the ranches and that'll kind of be
our action item when we come back we will have that with your guys's feedback and everything as far
as the approval next step
so one question in the data that you're evaluating when you do these traffic studies so connecting to
saratoga springs does it anticipate the population growth that will be occurring
in that land that's currently undeveloped because i think saratoga springs i think has entitlements for
a significant number of homes going in at that location
say that out loud brett
say that it's 56 units it's about 56 units per acre is what they're intending to build there
i believe our news to you but we're aware of that
we based our results off modeling from the state transportation model and we had a modeler kind
of update with these connections and not in mind so if it's included in the state model and that was
some of the cut through data that we saw in the initial poll was some of that initially would cut
through kind of amount saratoga heading up north that was some of the movements we saw in the initial
study until kind of mountain view kind of comes down and is that more the regional draw so so
we're assuming that saratoga is uploading that data somewhere to a state database and you're pulling
that down from the state database is that how that works state model
yeah so the two mpos um really across the wasatch front mag and wfrc uh they they have their planners
that collect all the socioeconomic data all the projected growth from all the city master plans
they put it into this one model and so as we look at our future projections is taking all all those
assumptions that the cities have documented um into account could we verify that that data is included
in this study because that's really the key in my mind to understanding this if this is just using
because because mag is always behind in what they're uploading there's just i mean let's be real
and so i think it's really important that we have accurate data that this is based on yep absolutely and
that's why the attachment was a draft report we want to get this feedback and so we can double check those
numbers before we finalize that report update the transportation master plan
now if you would go back to or maybe it's here but it's basically woodhaven and uh silver lake no no
yeah by the school so it's golden eagle golden eagle there you go and you and i have talked about
this a lot and i but i don't know if these guys were given that i can't tell because of the size and
but i right here there's a little pinch point did you fix that yep we fixed that and as well as down
on this end is that the part on the east end is not included in that estimate this is just the
intersection that would be something else we have to look at but we did fix that this is all widened
already but i did get saratoga talked into making this uh 77 i believe and it now is added to their rtp
so so so this road does extend but at the connection our side is 59 or it's it's local we're 59 so i just i
want to make sure that that gets corrected and that it matches and that we don't have a pinch point right
there as that goes forward whether it's in the funding or whatever but as far as the drawing and
i know there's some hoa there might be a little negotiation going on but that that's yeah i
think i think with with the school coming online in um i've been told fall 28 for the high school
you know we want to present this study update the transportation master plan and if council is
in agreement with that we could hopefully proceed with design you know later this year early next year
maybe get knockout construction in 27 so we're ready for high school in 28. that was kind of our perceived
schedule but again we want feedback and comments from you guys as well so as far as the connection to the
east you know we probably recommend doing that when saratoga makes that connection just for the
efficiency we really wanted to focus on just these movements as long as it's on our rtp so they don't
try to connect to a narrow obviously you and i are both in contact with them but uh make sure that their
engineer is also on board with the it's not correct now yeah it's on there and you know we and i'm glad the
residents are all here we want to make more connections we have more redundancy and connections
that helps with safety you know less accidents and things of that nature but we want to do it
smartly that's why we're doing these studies so we understand the volume the safety and then doing
the speed study where we find these issues because we're not just blindly connecting neighborhoods and
just i don't remember the other road but saratoga shows a connection up up
brookwood that's it yep also so there's also an anticipated connection up there that i think is
important to this discussion right sure yep that's also looked at so any other questions comments
i'm just going to say i think one of the things i think we briefly mentioned it but i just want to
make sure again with all the residents here so they're able to understand how speed limits are determined
so the the type of road that it is dictates that so golden eagle is a minor arterial collector
minor collector it's been changed to mine it was always a minor collector golden eagle is a minor
collector because that's that's a matter collector and our minor arterial is a 122 five lane that's
porter's crossing the board's crossing is a major collector the report says it says minor arterial in
the report yeah it's actually that that could be a typo then because golden eagle is a minor collector
it's a 77 foot right away port is crossing is a 94 foot right away as a major collector so then it
absolutely is yes that was that was probably the speed limit is totally wrong on it because it does say
that in there and that's what our original understanding was for golden eagle is that it was a larger
collected collected collector major or even a minor arterial so we need to straighten that part out and then
uh with the changes that you're proposing to woodhaven boulevard will that change its level of service
and the type of road that it is from a minor collector to something bigger um the right-of-way would
still say the same i mean we were looking at it i think it was still 40 feet of pavement it would just
function better because after where the current roundabout is the road widens up and so it would really
just help with the turning movements at the intersection we're not looking to necessarily make this a
five laner over there so it'll stay at 35 miles an hour and then obviously we're going to have to deal
with some of the consequences of that it'll give us straight away for traffic that already travels way
too fast on that road so currently yes but part of that speech study is obviously this road and then
the other intersections in the vicinity so that's something we want to look at as well is evaluating
speed because we know this is a high volume road and we want to size it appropriately for speed because
if it's too slow people will go way too fast if it's too fast it goes too fast so we have to find
that kind of golden middle ground people will comply and not over speed so that's our goal is correct
correct me if i'm wrong but there is some room to wiggle on that our standard is if the roads this
width or that width this is the proposed speed limit but a council could determine that any speed limit is
right and maybe 25 isn't right maybe 35 but 30 and that's that could be a decision of the council correct
that that is correct that's how our code is written and in our tmp it's a range it's not like minor
collector is this major is this there's a range and we can look at that from council feedback crash
history speed studies and then we present that information and that's what we're going to do kind
of next steps i think given what road it is i think 25 i think 30 might i think that's something we
definitely want to take a look at i think there's arguments to be made for a number of the roads that
they've talked about those of you that have talked about silver creek way we're aware of the problem
it's one of those that we're going to evaluate particularly where it goes over the wash and
they come flying down the hill both directions so all of those things are going to be contemplated on
speed how we can calm some of those things so i appreciate you bringing that to our attention that
we're doing a speed study throughout the city and in particular areas starting with our elementary
schools middle schools and high schools i hope are part of that as well to make sure that we're
starting with our pedestrian population which is mostly kids and then we start looking at some of the local
roads that have extra lengths and maybe even more narrow roads which i think a lot of those that are
some of the older neighborhoods would fall on that so thanks any other comments or questions for
go ahead i just want to clarify the information that we're looking to
secure or confirm i think is probably a better word verify isn't just population it's based on
what's vested and what's moving forward in these cities so yes mag is always wrong when it comes to
our population but knowing what's vested and what's planned for an area i think is more instructive
for this decision process so if you could confirm that that would be great thank you i will i agree
with that comment is that something that saratoga springs is willing to share and i know that they're
in in a hurry to build the road it'd be really great to see what around the road they're anticipating
i'm sure we do our evaluations we want that information i think that would be good to know i'm sure they
can i have a great relationship with both the city engineer and the assistant city engineer so we'll
get that i can i can tell you my recollection and i don't want to speak for anyone but at least the
what i've been told and what i remember the best of my knowledge is and when i said that 56 units
the acre it's similar to some of our older mdas where they were given 10 000 units with density transfer
it's 18 000 that's the number yeah i mean it's it's a lot and some of ours i was saying are that and
they transfer density this is getting towards the end of the project and they're looking at that number
that's left based on the acreage that's left and the number is 56 units the acre do i believe or do they
believe that they'll actually build 56 units of the acre i don't think that's the case but i i know that the
the the landowner's entitled to x number of units and that's how much land's left so will it fit will
it will they do that i i don't think it matches the rest of their code just my personal opinion
um but my understanding is they had 5 000 acres that were part of that and they've used up 2 000. so
there's still quite a bit of land to be able to make those decisions and they are entitled to 18 000
mayor karn i'm trying to remember what the number was that he told me uh that they have already built
but it's maybe a third of that uh on that uh area where they have i can't remember what it's called
as a wag is what it's called i was thinking you were talking about the layer it starts with a w um
all the church uh owned property is the same on there yeah no there's a there's a term that they
use for it's like a master development agreement basically so yes if you have that kind of relationship
that information is vital to know what we're inviting to come push back the other direction
through there we need to know that information as well okay we can take a look at that and if it's
off we'll just rerun things and we can always update our recommendations with a master plan
and and i've heard from the mayor uh exact same thing from the city manager that yes these are the
numbers but other aspects of their agreement and and their zoning can strain it down so that they're
not actually going to be able to materialize that many numbers i would just say a couple of other
things david that i think you that we ought to see if we can advance a little bit with this if i mean
if this in fact is going to happen and it looks more probable to me that that's going to happen than not
i would say this i think that especially if we're going to be making those improvements on woodhaven
already we should just go ahead and get rid of the mailboxes we should take care of that in this funding
cycle that eight thousand dollars from my perspective pull it out of the the contingency and just take
care of that take care of whatever they're doing the work and the white line striping um by silver
lake elementary golden eagle silver lake by by the elementary they're saying that that's one of the
recommendations that hell's made i think we should just get that done i don't there's not a cost
associated with that but it can't be much do you want to do that instead of the speed tables that we
funded well i think that we ought to i think we ought to do both i think the speed tables need to happen
but i also think the striping we were planning to do anyway the parking the parking the issue on that
and that striping will help designate or at least yeah at least designate this is parking and this is
roadway right correct so i think we ought to be doing that we can do that now and we've had success with
the striping efforts and other roads too where we have like a fog line there's like an eight foot pulled
in so you have designated parking and it pushes the vehicles closer together without having the center double
yellows and that creates the effect of being closer people naturally slow down and that's been successful
in some areas we've done in the city and then my next question is the mag funding i mean have we got
pony express expansion to seven lanes on a tip yes yep it's it's it's not on the tip it's on the rtp
okay um the next tip cycle is not the 28 and i'm hoping to uh apply for that in 28. okay i just wanted
to make sure that we're being proactive about that it's on there we actually have woodhaven on there as
well but it didn't score well correct correct we had this connection on there and it did not score
well from around from a regional it was even lower than wild blossom unfortunately yeah because it
connected to saratoga i tried to push this one but it is on the rtp and one of the things we're trying
to do is add all these regional connections on the rtp because even if we can't get tip funding like
wild blossom one of the things i was going to mention to you after our last meeting we could go over for
corridor preservation funds potentially for some of these it's not a big fund but we could use some of it
to start to get right away and kind of advance some of those smaller projects to medium projects
three million dollars in there i mean it's something worth going after so on the tack committee make
sure we do that yep yep i've been talking back about that so it's on rtp pardon me go ahead and then
then i think that we uh i think that we need to be looking at where we're going to find 3.9 million
dollars to make those improvements on the silver lake side if we're going to do it if we're going to do
both the roundabout removal and a signal and take care of that intersection you're talking about and the
adjustments to wood haven and pony express excuse me silver lake parkway where it comes down you know
you're going to get me in trouble with both my mother and my sister my sister lives on silver creek
way she was frustrated when we made the connection across the wash because she was sitting on a dead end
street i want you guys to know that we get in trouble with everybody okay she was not happy about
that my mother lives on campbell circle and if we're going to close off her access she's not going to be
happy about that so um we take the heat from all sides i just want you to know that and what we're
really interested in is trying to come up with the best solution and i think you've presented at least
something that we should be we should be pursuing
i don't see any other go ahead this is an easy one just going up to that's brookhaven that's where
your kids go to school um when i walked that it was wild i think it was on a friday afternoon
school was getting out and there were just kids all over the roads running yeah at brookhaven or silver
lake brookhaven okay the answer is yes i was at brookhaven and there were kids just run like running
down the street and you know the signage on that road i went up golden eagle there's trees in the way
i don't know do we know is that like hoa property or can we trim that stuff so some of them we have
trimmed recently actually because i know i drive that way did it in the morning we did trim those
because yeah because the the school zone flashings were covered yeah it's like pointless they are
they are trimmed yeah because that was the comment i made because i said because they grew in pretty
quick they filled up fast and so we trimmed those down we even pulled one of them out that was
blocking actually okay thank you yeah
okay yeah that was just a discussion item it looks like we wrapped that up so thanks to our partners from
hills uh appreciate you guys being here and helping us out that and david for all the work you've done
um and the council for a good discussion and now that everybody's here for the budget
we'll go on to uh all right mass exodus sit uh item 16a i thought they were coming for the budget
um that this is a public hearing but we will first just wait for it to settle down just a little bit
but kimberly's going to be coming up to talk to us about our 2025 2026 i believe
we did go over this a little bit in our work session and this is the third amendment actually i think that all
all the information is in there i don't unless there's any questions uh for council 16a is the the
amendment to the 2025 2026 physical budget is is there any questions for staff kimberly's here prepared if
there are if there's no questions ahead of time it is a public hearing so let's roll right into that
uh it is 8 32 and we will open the public hearing on this item don't all storm at once is there any
nothing not seeing anyone confirming with lacy we will close the public hearing at 8 33 and bring it
back to council for any further discussions or a motion mayor i'll make a motion if that's okay
i move that the eagle mountain city council adopt a resolution approving the third amendment to the
2025 2026 fiscal year annual budget as uh as presented in our packet second
okay we have a motion by council member wright and a second by council member clark we'll start
the voting with council member whiting yes council member wright
yes council member clark yes council member hewish
no council member wood no that passes three to two
the uh next item
if you'd like to make a statement you're welcome to i could have paused for a minute but you don't have to
i'm i'm supportive of the tax increase and i like where we're going with the public safety i think
i'm just a little bit more on the conservative side with staffing um well this one was this is the
last year's budget amendment oh sorry so that that's on uh two items from yeah okay i'm going i'm
getting ahead motion to reconsider i'll reconsider yes is that okay to change the vote or doesn't change
anything um can he you know you've already kind of declared the motion is passing so i don't see i
don't see any reason to allow him to change his vote so that it's passing by a greater majority
yeah it's it's fine i mean if you wanted to state for the record that that was a mistake and that you
would have voted the other way i'm okay with that because it will reflect it in the motion in the
minutes but i'll restate my vote to a yes they can't change it but you could state that you
want the record to reflect that was like the record to reflect i support the amendment thank you is
is that a uh fair statement okay yeah that i think that's the the proper way rich did you have anything
okay uh next item is 17a this is also a public hearing uh pursuant code 10-3-818 this is a law
that was changed a couple years ago about any compensation increase every year it has to be
brought before the public for public hearing for executive officers so the physical year 2026 2027
is uh this is a public hearing so i think we're all aware of why this will come up forever about
this so are there any questions nothing um it is also a public hearing so at 8 35 i'll open the public
hearing on this item and ask lacy if anybody's here to no one all right seeing no one it is 8 36 and
we will close the public hearing at this time i should ask was there anyone here that did not
get the opportunity to speak on this item okay i still don't see you and that public hearing
is closed and bring it back to the council based on 17a any questions comments that's just the public
hearing only what's that it's a public hearing oh i'm on the wrong page is why i told you i was off my
game today so that's a motion only or sorry a public hearing only all right now information 17b
glad i got back to that paper so my instructions are correct uh this is the is also just information
only it's proposed property tax impact schedule uh with that i will read the proposed property tax
uh schedule this was as of i think it's important as of june 11th because the the county will give us
the actual number on the 22nd oh that's it now okay we're good we're good okay i had it incorrect
earlier when i was talking to the mayor in our meeting before the meeting okay kimberly's correct
okay sounds good so proposed property tax impact schedule eagle mountain city will consider
an increase to its property tax rate to generate an additional six million nine hundred fifty eight
thousand one hundred and forty one dollars the following information is intended to provide
decision makers and the public with an explanation of how city's operations would be affected in the
proposed property tax increase is adopted if the property taxes adopted eagle mountain city's current
property tax rate is zero point zero zero zero five three four eagle mountain city's current property
tax revenue is two million eight hundred thirty nine thousand nine hundred ninety eight proposed revenue with
tax change would be nine million seven hundred and ninety eight thousand one hundred and thirty nine
so the new property tax revenue to eagle mountain city would be six million nine hundred and fifty eight
thousand one hundred and forty one dollars estimated increase to eagle mountain city's property tax revenue is
two hundred and eighteen percent estimated increase to the average primary residence if the market value was five
five hundred thousand uh estimated tax increase was three hundred and twenty dollars and fifty eight cents
total city tax uh four hundred sixty seven dollars and forty three cents estimated increase to average
business if the market value was two million five hundred and fifty four thousand three hundred and three
the estimated tax increase would be two thousand nine hundred and seventy seven dollars and sixty two cents
for the total city tax of four thousand three hundred and forty one and sixty two cents
the affected budget is the sheriff contract the proposed budget of nine million seven hundred and ninety eight
thousand one hundred and thirty nine budget number tax change eight million two hundred and say again
oh sorry i didn't okay budget no tax change eight million two hundred and ninety thousand and budget
change one million five hundred and seven thousand nine hundred and thirty nine if a new property tax
increase is approved the revenue will be used to fund essential public safety operations at the
level approved by the city council these funds will help support core functions of the utah county
sheriff's office eagle mountain division including the addition of deputies to meet the growth of the city
that is part of the impact schedule and now we can move on to item 17c which is a public hearing it's a
resolution to the mountain city utah adopting the physical year 2026 2027 interim budget and the proposed
certified tax rate and discontinuing debit book service debt book service
any questions comments on item 17c this is the one that i think you've been waiting for
so no questions comments anything for kimberly that if not we will go to a public hearing at 8 40.
time for a public hearing it is 8 40 and we'll open the public hearing and
if you first of all let me uh ask is there anyone that has nothing anyone in the audience who would like
to speak please come forward and if you'd state your name for the record and then fill out a paper
uh colby curtis silver lake uh do you want a second paper for this one okay perfect i will do it for
you um so first of all i i appreciate the work that you're doing i trust your judgment um for for me i
i think it's probably more of a point of information is just to understand how we got to this point
because from my perspective um i would have conversations with both evo and paul all the time
about whether or not we needed to adjust taxes um and i was always told it wasn't it wasn't necessary
and then all of a sudden we have a a significant increase now whether or not it's warranted my
question is is is really how did we get here because i i don't see that from from my side because it
wasn't that like i don't i don't like to raise taxes i don't like to raise fees but i'm the kind of
person that if it's going to be for core services like sewer water roads then yes this this is that
kind of situation um but you know if there's anyone that can maybe highlight or help me understand
and and i'm not looking to throw anyone under the bus i just want to understand
what has happened uh to to get us to that point anyway thank you appreciate your time i think the
we haven't raised our property taxes in quite some time and our cost of public safety is
substantially increasing year over year we have about 2.8 million is that what it was 2.8 million that
we're collecting on property taxes and our public safety bill is 8 million right now for i think i can
speak for most of us up here the the decision to propose a tax increase was based on public safety
for those reasons only because that's a direct service to every resident that lives here and as
more residents are added that will go up for every resident that comes into our city and it pays for
somebody showing up when you're having the worst day of your life so to get to that number we had to
increase the number of uh deputies but also the increase the costs go up substantially every year with
cost of deputies and services etc so that's that's how we got to that point of we're going to fund public
safety the tax increases for public safety um and that will be something that as residents are added to the
city that will help pay for that increase in services for our public safety going forward
ladies first okay um i think i can speak to this as well because i served with those city managers as
well and for a really really long time eagle mountain has prided itself in being lean and being really good stewards
of the taxpayer dollars of the taxpayer dollars and we still are lean and really good stewards of the taxpayer
dollars the difference is that we have been basically subsidizing the chunk of our budget that should be
going toward public safety with every other department that we have including water sewer you know all of the other things
and we could continue to do that we could continue to subsidize our public safety with
the rest of our departments but we've repeatedly heard from our residents
um we need more services we we need to make sure that these things are being taken care of we have more water
mains breaking we have more you know sewer issues all of those things are happening but we're not able to
increase the staff and those essential services departments because again we've been subsidizing public
safety on the backs of our existing employees and when you look at the number of employees
that we have compared to cities that are similar in size and population and maybe even land mass
we have like half of what we should have and that half means that every single one of our employees is
doing the jobs of two three four people and while i wholeheartedly support the city managers that i've
worked with and respect them a ton there's kind of a reckoning that takes place this year with our budget
do we continue to sacrifice our existing employees so that we can increase how many deputies we have
or do we as the elected officials that were elected to make this tough decision
make this tough decision and course correct and get ourselves into a better place when it comes to it
and as difficult as it is to look everyone in the eye and say yes we're raising your property taxes
or we're proposing to raise your property taxes that's the very thing that you elected the six of us up
here to do and it sucks it's the hardest thing i think we'll ever do sitting up here but it's the job
it's what we were elected to do and i refuse to do it on the backs of our existing employees anymore
so the way that i'm looking at it kobe just to answer your question and and i would agree with with
what's been stated the sheriff's office reported to us that today we're at a one to 2200
per sheriff per person in in the city so our ratio is is very low relative to other cities
and what we're trying to do is increase that so we added or are considering adding with this tax increase
uh i think sit one sergeant no six is that right one sergeant six deputies thank you that's the word
i'm looking for so seven in all and that cost is is about 1.25 million in salary car all of that so
when you do the math you say okay we've got a 6.9 million dollar tax increase the safety is 1.25
million what are you doing with the other 5.6 million dollars and i think that's where
we're trying to land in where where should that money go should it go more towards capital projects
should it go to more towards uh staffing in conversations that i've had with zach hilton and
others i'm like why don't we have our paver machine out every day making trails in the city
and connecting and zach's response to me is i need people to run it we've got the machine we just
don't have the people and so now it's trying to kind of strike that balance if we can look at it from
a principle of property taxes pay for our safety so if we need more sheriffs then that's going to come
from property tax and that may be incremental each year we haven't had a property tax increase in
i think 15 years so it's pretty major you know it's been it's been a long time my property tax on my
house for the last 10 years has been about 200 bucks per year i was floored when i actually looked at
my statement you know because you look at your property tax that's alpine school districts increasing
taxes fires increasing taxes what are the other districts central utah water so you see your taxes
going up every year but when you look at your eagle mountain property taxes they have not really moved
in over a decade and so what's happening is the staff is getting more and more and more max trying
to load on more with trying to keep our wells running you know using duct tape and so i think we just
kind of look at and say can we alleviate some of that pressure by bringing on more staff and
up our services within the city so that's where i kind of landed i think i'm wrestling a little bit with the
council on how much of that should go to staff and how much should go to building roads that are that
are needed and and these different capital projects so i'm i'm really torn so i i mean i want to say
something about this because for me zach just hit the nail on the head i mean he's been paying 200 in
property tax to eagle mountain city for 15 years your tax rate's been flat but you paid every year is the
same and has been for 15 years and yet the services that you receive have increased in cost every year
year after year and so somebody's making up that difference or somewhere that difference is being
covered and where that difference is being covered is in the other revenue streams that go into the general
fund and i know you'll understand that colby so we're using sales tax revenues to fund essential services
and that's great as long as you can continue to to to collect a pile of sales tax revenues in excess of
what your needs are the reality of it is is we're not doing that and so we've found it necessary to at
least evaluate this and look at it and consider this and i'm not proud of being a member of the council that is
having to evaluate that and come to a decision on it but the reality of it is is is if we find it to be
necessary for the long-term health and well-being of the city then i'm okay with it the other thing
that we hear all the time residents will say this well there's you're adding more rooftops and more
people are coming in so every one of them are contributing more tax dollars to your property tax
and while that's true remember that they're contributing it at a rate that doesn't cover the cost
and so is that a good decision by us to continue to do that or do we just finally look at it and say we
we're going to have to find a way to make sure that the essential services are covered
and they do all that we can to grow the business side of it so that we have some additional revenues
in sales tax revenues met and other revenues to be able to make sure that we're taking care of park
maintenance how many people have come to that dais colby and beat us up about not taking care of our open
spaces and the reality is we don't have the resources to take care of it period because we're dumping it
into paying for essential services so that that's part of the reason why i've been okay with working
through this process and at least evaluating it
one other item that you know you didn't i didn't realize until you you get to the seat and you start
looking at a bunch of numbers and our average employee here in the city is is underpaid we're behind the
curve and so how how much like how do you as citizens feel when you find out that the average
employee of this city is underpaid
and if you were in my chair and had a chance to vote to give them a little more money
i mean how would you feel if you're at your employment that's not here the city you're you're
employed and you're underpaid let's say you are underpaid according to your market wage
i think that'd be an issue and so that's another thing we have to evaluate is i i i find it
unacceptable for us to be behind the the curve on this our our employees need to be paid market wages
um and what was you know there was a we were one of these budget meetings a month or two two or three
months ago and we're evaluating okay how much should we propose for an increase for the for the employees
and what the employees had told us was something like three percent we were the ones as a council
said no you can't we're we've got to do more than that they were they were still willing to keep the
belt tight but we can't let the belt be tight on the employees and we can't be behind on our public
services when it comes our public safety we can't be behind on any of that and so that for me
merits consideration for a tax increase if if alone just to pay the the the citizens the employees of
the city market wages if just for that alone but we have other reasons unfortunately we need to do
this for and i think part of the challenge is our city has doubled in size in about five years maybe
six years we went from about 40 000 to about 80 000 and so that i think is part of why the numbers
have had to change so drastically in so short a period of time um i i you know i'm a fiscal
conservative and i and i don't like that i okay i get elected and the first thing i do when it comes
of money is to to to tax increase but something i i will commit to this to the citizens we we do have
income that is going to be coming in larger quantities from our commercial sector from data
centers it's not here yet and but it but it's on its way it'll be interesting to see how much it
actually is once it comes through the door and if that starts coming through the door to where it's
giving us supplying our needs i'm definitely interested in looking at a re-evaluating this again and
looking at a tax decrease to to go to go back but we can't wait for that money to come in
yet we've got to act now and then evaluate it again once once that money from data center starts
to come through the door then we can start to reevaluate and maybe do a tax decrease and so
should my vote be yesterday but i i will commit that there will be a re-evaluation of this once
once that other income from the business sector starts coming through the door
and i just wanted to kind of elaborate a little bit on that there's no question that i also agree
that if if the uh income was to exceed our needs that we would have to evaluate that but remember
uh for instance when i read this an estimated tax increase on a uh business one from 2900 to 4300
the same thing happens to the data center if we drop taxes by ten dollars on the resident we drop
by millions of dollars on the data center so we got to be careful that that that we don't overcorrect too
much uh in my opinion we do we got to evaluate that make sure but it would also be just as easy to provide
better and more meaningful services and keep those taxes where the data centers are are that are bolstering
the the budget so it's kind of a fine line and a balance there uh to be careful of uh i believe everybody
had a chance to weigh in on on their thoughts here is there any questions any comments can i miss say one
last thing i think that it needs to be really clear too that this budget increase yes it's so that we can
course correct and get public safety taken care of but holistically the budget does include the things
that we have been planning for capital improvements it it covers the employees that were asked for and
we um aren't just looking at employees we're making sure that we're taking care of the improvements
and the things that our residents have asked for yeah all of the things um so it's not just about a
certain number of employees it's about the things that people have asked for and the employees are going
to be the ones that help us take care of those capital improvements
it's it's probably important to state too and i think it was stated but just overtly state we want
a well-balanced city we want a city that's fiscally diverse so that we avoid risk in the future and
and making sure that our most essential service is paid for with our most stable revenue source property
taxes to public safety but that allows us to then have money for things like um you know improvements
to silver lake and being able to make a connection and have the resources to be able to put a road in
that would have maybe torpedoed the city completely if it wasn't on our horizon right and so it gives
some flexibility to add parks or add amenities or take care of open space it makes you fiscally
diverse so that you can have a well-balanced city moving forward
sorry one last comment on this too i mean we've got to project which where do you want the city to go and
what do you want it to be the risk we have being off the i-15 corridor is we could become the armpit
of utah county because we're too far distant from employers that's that's a risk we counterbalance
that by providing superior service superior goods superior superior quality superior of quality of life
all that takes a little bit of money and so i'm willing to i'm willing to combat that and make us something
that is superior
okay so i had opened the public hearing we got a comment and uh just a reminder to fill out the paperwork
he's not listening to me will you remind him to keep him in line okay good and uh we did not close
the public hearing was there anyone else here on that to speak on this item yeah go ahead
and state your name and then for the record my name is austin bailey um i live in the new parkway
fields uh development um a lot of us that are moving out there are already strapped for cash
um we've spoke with our mortgage lender um a 218 percent tax increase could potentially increase our
mortgage by fifteen hundred dollars a month um that would be and i say potentially um i'm not saying
that's a given but i i just want um some extra concern and thought to be taken into account for
those that are moving out there um because homes are cheaper in eagle mountain um that um we aren't
potentially pushing people away from eagle mountain um because of the tax increase and the implications
that are a possibility on mortgages and um rates of those nature okay let me address the question here
just real quick so that you understand how taxes work the what uh i think zach or somebody over here
mentioned a minute ago it's not 218 on your entire tax bill for instance the county and all those people
you pay the water district as he mentioned you pay the county you pay the school district
so if the entire bill went up 218 percent it might be 1500 what this uh estimated average
resident of 500 000 the tax increase would be 320 a year for a total of 567 all year
so that's that's that's 30 dollars for those yeah a month it's just like mayor i was just gonna say if
you have your property tax payment it gives you a little pie chart i would encourage everybody just
to go look at that i was floored i pulled it out from 10 years ago and i'm like i have not been
paying the city what i should probably owe the city so yeah that is not that high it's it's 30 bucks a month
man it's 24 a month 26 26 on an average home so so that's you know two three hundred dollars
but but i think it's noted that a tax increase is a tax increase yeah it doesn't that's so we we have
to deliver on what's going to happen in the city yeah so with that is there anyone else that came to speak on
this item hi i'll make this brief charlotte ducos i'll fill out the form um one of the things that
i would love to see from this um with the with the 218 increase and and i think i've talked with several
of you about this before um we need a we need a mechanism where we're revisiting both our tax rates
and our impact fees and anything that we levy as a city where we're we're looking at those on a regular
basis um i know nobody ever likes to raise taxes but if we raise it by one percent because of a specific
thing it's a lot better than 218 and i know i'm preaching to the choir on that and i just think
that if we don't already have uh something in writing that asks us to do that on a yearly or a
you know however whatever we want that um interval to be um i think that needs to be something that is
in writing um we uh we've tried to be lean for a really really long time um but eventually being
lean for a really really long time leads to a 218 percent increase because you can't cover your
expenses and so while i um i'm not big on raising taxes all the time either um i do recognize that
taxes is how we pay for services and um and so sometimes they have to go up because our costs are
going up and um if we have a regular interval where we look at that then we're recognizing that those
costs are regularly going up and that we are regularly growing and so that would be my encouragement is
that we have that mechanism put in place if it isn't already in place and that we do um that
reckoning more often and um at a regular interval i think that's a a great point to have a written
policy i believe we're we're looking at that right now with this tax increase have we evaluated i think
it puts us in the in the lower third still yeah so after the increase across cities i know it's in
the lower half we're we're second to the lowest the only city in utah county lower than us is cedar
fort and that's another just fun point that 218 of a dollar it's only 218 dollars right because
we're so low to begin with where a city one of our neighboring cities raises 11 and it's more than
our 26 dollars and i think that's why that number seems scary but it's uh it's because the the multiplier
is so small i think is the the point there but still we'll be in the bottom half yeah we'll be even
after i believe we'll be very close to average yeah well and that's before all them jump back up because
every city but two raised that's that's exactly it most of the cities um also interest north of provo
and i actually think most of the cities in utah county are raising this year so even though we
project it to be the middle it's probably going to be in the one third
i think i think charlotte brought up a great point uh when we first had to start talking about this at
our retreat i even asked if we could like put a sunset clause in our tax but unfortunately it's not
allowed i would be willing to sign a pledge or something else that we revisited every year whatever
mechanism it takes for us to make it our culture that we're going to review it consistently i'm willing
to do it because i think it's important we do have financial policies in our budget and the whole
budget process is of course an evaluation by our elected leaders as far as our budgetary needs for
the new year we can make it a very overt if it's not already i'm looking at kimberly now if it's not
overtly and an item that is re-evaluated each year of course we're going through all of our impact
fees right now on a regular basis we want to do it more rapidly than the five-year minimum because
for such a high growing city that we know we need to to move more quickly on those um so i i think
absolutely we could do all the the council has just said right there and be fiscally responsible all
the way through at the same time
so still open in the public hearing and there's been a lot of comment uh
so okay he wants to come speak yep go ahead we're still in the public hearing and maybe we'll hold
our comments for a minute i think that's what's dragging us out let everybody speak so i close
this public here i'll keep the dad jokes out this time um justin cool evans ranch neighborhood and
in eagle mountain i just i apologize if this is not the the proper venue so please keep me honest here
uh like was stated i understand that taxation needs to occur right we can't make something from nothing
i work in payroll i understand i i would absolutely be pissed off if i was underpaid drastically right
and on top of that if we're under personed right then we're also overworking so i'm underpaid i'm
overworking i honestly ask how are we keeping our employees honestly 100 right and and so this
absolutely has happened what i'm curious about is is do we have anything from a transparency standpoint
like are the the budgeting and things of that nature is that you know here's what we spent out here or
here's what we took in is that stuff readily available okay i just wanted to understand that
because that to me makes it a lot easier for me to say yes absolutely let's do that and then as voters
if we look at and go whoa whoa whoa whoa somebody is smoking something this doesn't make any sense
right then we can come back time later and go okay to your point also like can we reassess and taper
down if we need to as well right so i just wanted to then yes i'm i'm all for when it makes sense i just
wanted to understand if there was some transparency there so so appreciate that i'll also fill out my form
on that as well so okay is there anyone else yeah fill out another paper thank you are we going to run
out of paper back there okay good stephanie's on top of is there anyone else that came to speak on this
topic seeing no one i'm going to close the public hearing so that we can have the comments all uh
we'll close the public hearing at 906 and just on that one the entire budget is online at eagle
mountain.gov uh at our at our website so as far as the transparency pull it up on the website you'll see
everything that we spend kimberly keeps that up pretty good and we have one of the best financial
people around so if there are no other comments or questions from i know brett's itching to make
a motion or council member right i want to move us forward mayor if you'll allow me go ahead i move
the eagle mountain city council adopt a resolution adopting the fiscal year 2026 2027 interim budget
and the proposed certified tax rate and discontinuing the debt book services
second okay uh motion by councilman wright and second by council member whiting and uh is there any
questions on the motion can i just have a clarification do the tax increase and the budget have to be tied
into the same boat or can they be separate well what this does is it's an interim budget because it's based
on the our budget won't pass if we don't uh increase right it's tight yeah the final budget comes in august
as well as the public hearing
so any other questions on that
portion not you good no questions okay then we're going to start the vote right here with uh councilmember wright
yes councilmember clark yes councilmember hewish
no councilmember wood
yes councilmember whiting yes okay that passes 4-1
and i suppose the same comment from before right the employees and whatever you talked about before okay
we will move on to item 18a also public hearing of uh amending the eagle mountain municipal code 16.15
of the concept plans as presented earlier by um brandon but we'll turn time over to him for a little
a little explanation and then move forward sounds good um thank you mayor council um as as i noted earlier
this is really a a proposal to to improve our development process especially the front end of it
we're wanting to make sure that we're looking for utility and road connections early on in the process
um i know dave david salzar talked about this i'm passionate about it too we want to improve
uh transportation and traffic connectivity in the city and so i think that's going to help if we're
looking out for for uh road connectivity and utility connectivity early on i think we're gonna
going to uh have less problems as the development process as an application for development
uh moves on and i think you're gonna gonna see a better built environment in the city so essentially
what this is is it requires uh preliminary subdivision plats master plans and rezones to have a concept plan
and um and when when that application's submitted they're going to have this is basically saying they're
going to have to submit there's all most of these documents are already required we're adding one
but big thing here is i think we're adding some clarity to what's going to be required we beefed up
what's uh the kind of the descriptions for traffic circulation plan and utility infrastructure plan and
then added the concept street layout i think it's critical that we you know for instance number three
there i think we really need to be looking at street connect uh look looking at our master plan looking
at a development and seeing where the road connections need to be made so that's that's what what will uh
help here and again as i noted earlier we had a comment from a council member that kind of stuck in my ear a
little bit about trying to limit the number of concept plans that are coming to this body and so what i what i've
what i've what i've proposed here is to have uh generally have concept plans go through the drc and
and planning commission and then just kind of on a case-by-case basis if we need to steer steer
concept plan to this body so um but that's uh kind of the proposal in a nutshell i think it's uh we
we believe it's uh going to be a really helpful uh proposal uh amendment we've been talking with uh
public works brad trying to improve our process and this is just kind of a
there there will be an additional amendment that's going to add something to this um we've got another
amendment uh that's going to deal with water rights and our water rights process that will kind of relate to
this but um so there stay tuned for a little bit more but this is our first uh kind of effort to
just at least get the concept plan process working a little better
i have a question um i remember when we talked about doing the concept plans when that was passed
by the city council i think i was on the planning commission when this happened and the purpose of
that at the time was because there were so many plans that were coming that were basically a surprise
and city council was not in favor of it and so they were being rejected because there was no input
beforehand i worry about now taking this mechanism and pairing that down to the very same problem that
existed before that we returned back to the same problem that began here i think jared and melissa were on the
council at that time um i just love to hear everybody's feedback on that when that was
this concept plan uh code was created it was for that purpose so that they weren't spending
all of the money coming in and getting rejected
i think one of the other things along with that council member wood is um sometimes we're reluctant
as a council to create wide sweeping code that up would apply to everyone when we're only willing to
consider it in very small specific circumstances through maybe a development agreement and the concept plan
was the one way for them to be able to bring it in and see if the building height or the whatever
you name it that they wanted us to consider would be considered so i i agree with that that's not what
i was saying i was saying that if we take that away we're going to be surprised again i agree with you
that's i think i'm just trying to affirm what you're saying um but i also grow weary with some of the
multiple stops made on the concept plan train and how exhausting it is because it's one thing to come
and get our feedback it's another thing to use it to wear us down and i think that's where the disconnect
is i know it doesn't so
i'm going to tell you it doesn't wear me down i think it's better to have the conversation before
money's expended um perhaps that doesn't need to go through every single step perhaps because
it isn't an action that's being taken maybe it doesn't have to go through every one of the steps
that a normal application does and it brings it to us so we can give feedback and then send it through
the route maybe that helps i don't know who has the issue with it if it's a staff issue or if it's an
applicant issue i'm going to tell you i think the the benefit of the concept plan coming to us
is we just had an example of that not too long ago where the concept plan wasn't even close and
they wanted to proceed with this project and there were other considerations that we wanted to see on
there and we said come back and show us everything and that took some time for them to finally agree
to that but they eventually did where we could get to a yes or it would have been a no right off the
bat and now they're waiting a year so to me i think there's some benefit to doing that especially at the
stage that we're in now as a city where there's a lot of infill and a lot of this stuff is commercial
that's coming before us now um obviously you're going to have projects that are still coming with
housing there's just not a ton of that that's coming to us most of the stuff is commercial and
i think there's a benefit to seeing some of those things that's that's my opinion i don't want to
speak for everybody but i i like the concept plan coming to us because i think that gives us
the ability to tell them whether or not their project has any success is there a limit to how
many times it can come because parkway fields it was eight and eight times of not hearing no you can't
have four thousand units there is excessive lower hayden valleys come to you so and and because it's a
concept plan there's no denial that like is like this is serious pay attention to what we're saying so
i think that is the weary part like i 100 agree with you that i want them to come so that we can work
together and create something amazing together and help get them on the right track but when it's
eight times it feels egregious what i'm hearing from the two of you is perhaps just a difference of
opinion that that that this may not be the exact mechanism or perhaps is not the way that we should
proceed forward so my question is should we just consider tabling that and giving it some more work
perhaps the two of you could meet with brandon and help give some guidance that would adjust that
i'm i'm open to just keeping it to the council i have no problem doing that all i was trying to
do is like basically i think that's my question brandon to the council is do you want to pursue elevating
this and adjusting it to to eliminate some of the concerns that you have with the current situation
i what's your feeling on it i think let's hear from the other three what are your opinions melissa and
i have both given our opinions i personally think there's some benefit in making it better than what
it is because i share some of her concerns i think there should be a limit i think the process should be
pretty simple and straightforward and it shouldn't be lengthy and it shouldn't be expensive it should be
simple and it should get to a place where a developer has a feeling that okay there's a probability that
this is going to work or there just isn't and it looks like brad's going to come up and and give us
some information i see him coming to give you some help brandon so come on up brad
i just think as a public works division we support this improving this process and i think it's
something that needs to be done and i'm supportive of what brandon's doing here because i think we have
to be able to measure these developments against what our master plans are and we need to do that
in the initial reviews and we need to make sure that we can supply them with the utilities and everything
that we need to service them ongoing and that should all be done before they go spend money and get into
the process and so i just want to stand up here and support i know that you're talking about whether
it comes back to this body or not but from our perspective in collaboration and trying to get a
better product and a better outcome we support this because we feel we feel like it will make the
process better and it will help with the developers and i think i think you make a really good point
because i'm thinking of this as concept plan only but i really love the elements of introducing the
water documentation early on and the utility review all of those things so my question really is can we
improve upon this i mean it sounds like there's enough concerns with at least with these two that you
you don't feel like it's ready and maybe i don't want to put words i haven't well we're ready honestly to
we we need to get using these extra documents so we don't have additional applications come through
without this material that's why i'm hesitant to have a delay i i just as soon have you prove everything
with the idea of just letting it come back to the council and if we need to address that issue we can
come back and address i'm not looking to delay you maybe you misunderstood where i'm going i'm saying
the making sure that the public work stuff comes up front yeah would have been super beneficial for a
pretty large development not too long ago where there's a lot of challenges and i i'm totally in
favor of that what i'm saying is to eliminate the city council's input into that i'm not in favor of
the other thing too i'll point out is what what i've tried to do like a like i said earlier is like
gatekeep it a little bit more i'm not saying we're not going to bring concept plans to anymore we're just
going to be a little more judicious so it's the code saying it'll stop at the at the planning
commission but that doesn't preclude us from putting something on your agenda can you can you
can you just add one line in there that simply says that the city council can require that it come
before them yeah absolutely let's put that in there then then then it's up to the council to decide as
they see stuff going through planning they would probably have to at least let us know that there
is something to evaluate though yeah but it gives us the ability to pull it forward i think what you'd
want to do is maybe put a notification requirement our city code of course already allows the city council
to make become the land use authority on anything unless it's already unless it's prohibited by state law
so this would be something that you could become the land use authority on if you wanted to and the
only thing you need to do is know about it so a noticing requirement to city council that a concept
plan is going for planning commission is there any reason we couldn't do that in the that last section
on our agenda that has upcoming concept plans for us to review so it's in one place yeah we can put them
on there for you i and i'm good i don't i and i don't want to stand in the way of it either i think a lot of
the repeat offenders that keep coming back with concept plans would have been narrowed down or
screened i'm not going to use the word gatekeep if we had public works weigh in on it because that
would have settled a lot of the concerns that council had from the beginning and that's maybe that's
where i want to jump in a little bit i i want to help the council understand that there's other aspects
of this that will mature in time too last week we had a really good meeting going through water rights
and when water rights will be dedicated we're moving that up to concept and moving the requirements at
final up to preliminary so that we can have a better handle on that i think that the real moral of the
story is um one we want to be able to um look at the feasibility of things before they even come to you
because if they're not feasible we don't want to waste their time your time or not as as a staff we can
give a lot of information to them before they start investing dollars and and the second aspect of
that is we have a typical tendency to want to have perfect code and perfect processes and whatnot and
perfect plans and everything and so a lot of times we're not approving things or not moving things
forward in an incremental or iterative or stepped way that allows us to start making incremental
improvements knowing the other that we're going to continue to make these improvements coming forward
because sometimes we miss out on opportunities to fix processes because they never get over the
finish line you know what i mean so i just really want to stress that too and i'll say too um kind of
with with brad coming up what what uh also is going on behind the scenes brad and i are working together
with our two departments trying to fix things that aren't necessarily related to the code but more
like uh pro administrative processes um like with with that open gov tool that you've been gracious to
to provide that for us we're working to improve our development process to just make make the city
function better and to make the development process function better so can i jump in for about 45 seconds
promise all right this is a public hearing and we've made a lot of comment and i'm going to knock that
out so uh at 9 23 we'll open the public hearing and ask if there's anyone here is there anyone here
that wanted to comment on this code ah i thought we were going to get another dad joke that was close
um seeing no one we'll close the public hearing at 9 23 and bring them back to the council okay so
now that we got that out of the way we can see if there's something we can if we can get somewhere or
i think that that melissa made a good suggestion there needs to be a limit to the number of concept
plans they can bring back to us so you probably know better than anybody brandon what that should be
so suggest something to us and i think as far as i'm concerned everything else is great if we can put
it on our upcoming agenda items or something in that communication items section that allows us to
see the cut the and maybe some of those will just say don't bother bringing that to us because you put
in there they don't meet the these criteria in here they want to come forward but they don't meet up and
say yeah it's not ready to come to us then right i like that i want to empower you guys to say hey
this doesn't even remotely meet code so we're going to let you work on it some more like i just i i think
it's good to let you guys say this isn't going to council because it's definitely not ready so
one question i have on that though sometimes a developer is going to be talking to you about
something that's not necessarily public yet so if you're throwing that on our agenda saying hey
i met with the developer about this didn't meet code now suddenly it's public so i i don't know if
the our public agenda is the right spot for you to be able to give us a lot of detail i i would agree
and it may be easier i mean i know ben sends us an amazing email once a week that it's got to take
you like eight hours to write when i read through that i'm like this is an amazing email
super informative every single week that it's i mean i i really appreciate that
uh and maybe maybe there's just a once a week email as well that says hey here's some of the
things we're working that are happening that's happening in the with these plans but really a
notification just needs to come to council when it's ready to go to planning because if it's not
ready to go to planning we're not going to see it from my perspective i i mean that's just something
something that something the planning department or the recorder could do if it's going to planning and
she's sending out a public notice why not send out just a council notice that these concept plans are
coming to to the planning commission can we do that by text i don't need another email to try to find
i'd rather it come by text if that's possible i've got way too many emails as it is
two other people got to make a decision
with which i'm okay with it the way that it is just adding the requirement for a notification to
council about the concept plan that's going to the planning commission okay
okay i'll make another motion if you'll let me mayor you ready okay i uh i moved that eagle mountain
city council adopt an ordinance amending the eagle mountain municipal code 16.15 concept plans
and adding a condition that the accounts will be notified anytime a concept plan is going to be
is coming to planning commission for a public hearing is there one other thing we wanted to add
by text
right i'm going to let you guys figure that i'm not going to be that specific um and that's i'll second
your motion then
sorry i think uh i got council member right making the motion i think council member wood with the second
and we'll start the vote with councilman clark yes council member hughish yes councilman wood yes
councilman whitey yes councilman wright yes okay that motion passes good work
um there's john there he is legislative priority lists looks like we have some updates
good evening mayor council i have a few questions and a few updates um you guys had asked for a
seasonal sign ordinance that is going to go to the planning commission next week
they had to do the political sign at the same time so it was a little slower than we'd want it but
trying to match state law and do both at the same time the other question i have you talked about
and standardized poured concrete fence for eagle mountain um there's two companies that actually
make those in utah they pour them here they manufacture them here um the question is do you want something
off the shelf do you want something designed especially for eagle mountain um that is my question to you would
do you before i start getting prices custom are we talking about them pouring them for us do we own
the molds if we go with something custom we'd we'd have to own the molds i would say we want to hold them
own the molds so that if we decide this contractor is not the one we want to use that we can take the
mold to move them to another contractor for consistency right so we would but there's only two companies that
actually pour them in utah in our area so there's another kind of company that's larger um that does
the does the fences but they don't pour them in utah when we when i say custom are we talking about we
have some design control over what's stamped on the concrete the color what we want that those panels to
look like right because we can get something off the shelf what what does off the shelf look like
is it just like river rock some red some of it's kind of boring some of it's kind of hideous yeah i'm
going to go custom have you ever been up to harriman when they do these panels you'll go buy one and
it's got a tractor and like a wheat field or cornfield and a couple more down it's a different scene
the other ones are kind of standard but every they intermix these ones with uh reliefs on them
into the system so it's not just a big boring front wall so does that meet the the art desire that we
had to have that type of thing throughout the city to have something that's dealt with uh you know
like you see some of the overpasses that have the the 2002 olympic stamp on it or well i mean that's
that's that's trademarked right you'd have to be careful with that but right well i'm not talking
about that i'm just saying as an example that's what we're talking about you certainly could do
something custom like that i guess my question is i wouldn't want to deviate too far and i wouldn't
want to make it too hard and i wouldn't want to make it extra expensive that that would be my concern so
i think it should be fairly simple if you're going to do something that's custom
harriman only has like four custom panels and everything else is uh kind of a standard panel
and they just put them in every so often we're basically just buying the molds once
and then we're paying for them to pour them right right they would they would produce them as
their contractors would need them yeah but i mean for an example if you have a custom mold and it's
harder to pour and it takes more time and more labor are you raising the cost of that those are the
things that i would want to examine a little bit and be aware of we definitely don't want to do
complicated i'm thinking like a very simple something on what that is and whether there's four or two is
immaterial just something that creates some especially on the ones that are really long to have something
to break it up but maybe you could bring some things first to take a look at yeah i just wanted before
i started making these phone calls i mean i did look at the standardized stuff you could have a custom
panel and a standardized one so you can keep the cost kind of low my in my mind when we talked about
this probably a month or two ago it was really just the logo we just do this without the dates and do
the just the eagle and every fourth or fifth panel has this logo maybe one has the just the e
uh you do put brett right where it says 30th anniversary
yeah i think i'm a no
but uh you know i mean there's some easy things that would stay with the logo and then and if you
want to do anything beyond that whatever but but that's where i would stay so any uh further discussion
on that one you have some good direction yeah i'll hopefully i'll have something by the next time i
come back i'll come back with something all right anything else on the list anything need to be talked
about added brought up okay thanks sean thanks uh next item is uh council mayor comments and then uh liaison reports
so i know you've been yeah go ahead had a great chat with uh jim smith at the uh pony express rodeo and
just asked him to kind of give me a grade of how we did as a city and helping them to pull off the
rodeo and it was very complimentary said our staff was top notch in their help uh so i'm really appreciative
of the help in in helping them to to put together one of our our biggest events um they're a great group of
people i've worked with them for two and a half years now three almost three years um and they're
hard-working people they're dedicating their time and and they are true volunteers uh that are giving
up their time just like uh people on boards and commissions and so forth and we appreciate everything
that they did for us if you have a chance to see that they're all with exception of one i think they're
all residents of eagle mountain right i think there's only one that isn't all the rest of them are
residents so if you see see them uh the community thank them for the great sacrifice that they make
to put that uh event on for us
yeah i know the youth council they talk about the dance already so
yes the dance was i thought well attended uh it was fun i joined for a little bit i'm not a dancer
uh but i joined for a little bit nonetheless uh so that part was fun uh i actually wanted to bring
up and maybe this was i should have brought this up like a few minutes ago but uh ben had forwarded us
an email all right with a suggestion about creating a an advanced air mobility overlay zone
is that can we talk about that momentarily because you want to expand on that for us ben because i think
that's something we need to consider sure and this would be great with the legislative priorities and
whatnot so the state of utah has an advanced air mobility um advisory committee that they put together and abby
was was kind enough to get me included on that they're putting together a um a guidance document
that is going to help cities help to understand what is in the city's authority what's in the faa's
authority what's in between and udot aeronautics authority how the cities can help govern this through land
use and through zoning and whatnot and it would be great to have some sort of an overlay zone for us
to maybe be that uh first city out there to work with the uh with udot and with this advisory committee
to be able to craft an uh an overlay zone that we could use in our community as we move forward
and the nice way nice thing about doing it as an overlay is it doesn't actually apply to anyone's property
until such time as we determine you determine applicants come in hey where this word does
this make sense but give some guidance to those who might want to come into our community of some of
your expectations right up front so um i i think this is going to be something that's going to take some
time we'll get the guidance document out to you hopefully we can get it out to you earlier before other
cities uh even get it and uh and see where this goes for our community so is this something we need
that be acting on right now or is there something you're working on to bring to us i i think adding
it as as if this is something that the council is interested in in taking a leadership role in
throughout the state then i will uh actively engage in getting um this material out to all of you as
well as to our um our community development department to start drafting and putting together some code
they they were reluctant at one point they thought about putting together a draft ordinance but they wanted to
take a step back and they said you know every city is unique every city wants to do it their own way
here's some guidance some bullet points that we recommend rather than overly putting an ordinance so
it is going to be up to the cities to to determine what makes sense for us in our community
as far as what an ordinance looks like for eagle mountain city
i just want to clarify my understanding so air mobility what we're talking about is creating
ports from one city to another i can jump on an air taxi over utah lake go to linden catch it tracks to
salt lake that that's kind of what we're considering with this overlay zone like where could that happen
exactly so advanced air mobility is taking place in new york and la and in different places throughout
the world dubai and whatnot in the state of utah they want to have an active part of our transportation
network when it comes to the olympics when the olympics comes and so there's quite a bit of time between
now and then but in order to make that happen we really need to have many many different locations you
don't just have one report you have where you're going to and of course salt lake airport provo airport
ogden are very logical locations park city and other skiing destinations make sense as far as that's
concerned but eagle mountain really has an opportunity from economic development standpoint we of course have
a lot of people coming into our community large investors and whatnot looking at infrastructure and
and putting investment into our community so there's that aspect of it there's there's delivery of of
goods and materials and and and all that type of thing but more importantly for a city like eagle mountain
we really can be a backbone we have great airspace we have the land to do it we could be a great backbone
to this type of industry not only through manufacturing but being a hub yeah that and that's more what i'm thinking
is just warehousing we have a lot of land to store stuff and to ship it out be a distribution center
that might be kind of cool but it's awesome to think about a distribution center that doesn't use
the roads correct yeah scarcity breeds creativity we do not have roads but we have air
so last thursday last thursday last thursday i was at wasatch high school which is right next to hebrew valley
airport and i sat for four hours and i counted the number of times planes flew over the same planes
new planes i think my son got up to 52. um one of the things i think as we keep talking about this that we
need to evaluate what the actual impact of sound is going to be in our valley um i think all of these
ideas sound great and economic possibilities are awesome and being at the forefront of technology is
awesome but also there's an impact of these kinds of things that the quiet valley that we live in when
we start bringing those types of things in with frequency especially if you're looking at having
them deliver with frequency that sound is going to be reverberating throughout your valley and i think
as we're talking about this we're going to have this discussion about what that impact actually is
and is that something that we want to invite into the valley we've been very strict about what's in the
air what's on in the ground what goes into the water uh light but i think sound as we're going down this
this road is that something that we want to invite into the valley and does that change the
character of what we are i think that needs to be something we talk about you are dead on absolutely
right and that's one of the criteria that that the state is recommending every community look at
but what's really exciting about this technology is that the sound impact is one 140th the sound of a
helicopter because they're electric motors and whatnot and i guess i would maybe make it the equivalent to
the sound of an electric vehicle versus the sound of an automobile today on the roads they actually have to add
sound to the electric vehicles so you can hear them coming and uh and and that's that's uh really
going to change the dynamic of how all of this takes place but there's no doubt there will be an
impact and some people and there will be privacy law issues there's all sorts of things that need to be
considered that you as a council should be in the forefront of deciding
so something that i've been sitting back thinking this is a great conversation and stuff that we've been
working on especially manufacturing is it direction for ben to continue doing what he's doing
or is it something that you motion to put on the list so that you get more frequent updates that's i'm just
wondering what what the expectation is from here i would like us to get decibel information about
the noise that vertiports and this type of traffic would create yeah just the impacts but i don't know
that we need to add it to the list because we're already doing a study yeah and it's part it's part of
it it's the air mobility it's the so yeah i think after the study's done maybe we look at an overlay
zone if it makes sense if there's places within the city so maybe not just there yet okay in the
meantime i'll just keep getting you information so with that we were kind of on uh that took us back to
the legislative list but we were on the uh liaison stuff and i stayed at the dance until the lights went
out i think i turned the lights out if i remember right but uh go ahead just uh report on the most
exciting committee of all oh the one that presented tonight the audit committee oh shoot i fell asleep in
that media oh did i i don't know now everyone's gonna go to sleep
we had a great audit committee meeting today uh where we talked about uh risk assessment i just
wanted to report back some really positive things this was my first audit committee
meeting and i want to make sure that our finances are in good shape that we're protecting ourselves
from a risk perspective and i feel like kim and aaron are doing a very good job we have a very
reasonable audit cost and a good relationship with our auditor it's important because these kinds of
things going unchecked can create real risks anytime you have a distribution unintended going out that's
something that we that's why you have an audit to make sure you have controls in place
our score and i think this was somewhere in the agenda or maybe it was emailed to me from
kim we we have a very very low risk um we we scored i think it was 355 out of 375 we're missing a couple
points um but i think those are things that uh we're working on one of them is having our own internal audit
a lot of larger cities will have the staff to perform an internal audit i don't know that
we have the size of staff or that it really warrants if you vote for our budget we would
do you want to talk about that you want to go there we can go there everybody thought and i said
all right it's getting late we're missing a few points there and then we're missing a few points
on uh the just designations there are five or six different designations related to government accounting
that um i i think we have a staff employee that's working on getting that accreditation so hopefully within
the next year we'll have that sweet pretty good stuff and and i know i can't remember was it this
month i went to the seniors for you but there's didn't they need something no they came yeah you
want me to get yeah it was august they needed us or something yeah because that needs to be on our
radar i don't remember the date but it's in august i'll i'll have to remind you because i forgot already
i'm a senior you remember that man okay um but the seniors did come to the foundry for a tour and
they really enjoyed that we we we worked them over and they they they loved it they were actually there
while we did a pour uh and anyway that's the funnest part of coming on any foundry tour and drc's doing
fine yeah ulct we ben and i had a meeting with them not long ago and there's another one that's up and
coming i've actually volunteered to serve on a couple of committees that they that they're looking for
volunteers water is one of them and then thank you mayor for the opportunity to to be gone last council
meeting with many members of our staff to go attend a water conference in heber i felt like that was
really productive and i think you're starting to see some of the first results of that that are
coming through that one of them came through on our agenda today and i just want to express the
gratitude for the the staff that was there for the collaboration that happened and i just it was a
really impactful for me at least opportunity to really sit down and strategize with the with those
department heads and those that came and i think you're going to see the you're going to see the
results of that that will start to come to council periodically so anyway things going great on all
those committees i'm going to say thanks for being available and being willing to help pick up some
of that slack you've done a good job and i don't know if i'm supposed to say this but most of these
people probably don't know you couldn't get internet at the hotel so you drove in your truck and what
how many hours did you sit in the front seat yeah well as long as you guys were here till midnight i
was sitting in the park and looking like that waiting for the sheriff to come by and haul me away
um yeah anyway i uh i thought boy i i hope they're nice to me when they come and check on me
dedicated to sit in your truck and listen to us go on all night did you have some yeah um planning commission
has their new alternate uh laura jensen on and she's doing a great job with the rest of the planning
commission and they've been doing kind of a cool thing where there's different presentations during
their like work session time um and they're covering different topics and it's really neat because
they're using some of their uh talent and knowledge that's even on the planning commission to help
present those things um i also was just thinking about the fact that we had a fire last not this last
saturday but the saturday before and how crazy fast all of that moved and um no one's here from the fire
department but i think some pretty cool miracles happened that day and i'm really grateful for the
amazing people that we have serving us and how quickly that was pulled together and it's crazy to look
at the photos of the new high school that's being built and how it just like stopped and how it just
stopped before it took off across the field to all of our homes and silver lake and kiowa valley and
stuff like that so thank you to those that worked on that for us um and that's it okay if there's nothing
else we do have an rda meeting and we'll need about 35 seconds to switch the audio for stephanie but uh
any other go ahead motion to adjourn second uh yeah and that's the second time i'm trying it's all
right it's all right motion by council member wood and second by council member hughish we'll do a
voice of vote uh all in favor aye aye any opposed that passes unanimously and we will adjourn at 9 48.
give it a few minutes for the recording and start our rda meeting they can have all the seconds because i made
Thank you.